propose de commencer cette audition je
voudrais remercier ceux qui sont ici
merci monsieur le Président d'être avec
nous ce matin quand accompagné monsieur
gusta directeur général de la SN merci à
vous deux d'être là et pardon pour les
rangs un peu clairsemés mais comme vous
ne l'ignorez pas voilà nous avons des
nuages agitées en ce moment et agiter le
terme voilà en toute
c'est fait c'est enregistrer voilà donc
merci beaucoup de votre présence
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues je voudrais juste un petit
point de méthode non pas pour brimer la
parole parce que je voudrais pas être
accusé de telles propos mais parce que
nous avons un agenda serré nous nous
donnons une heure ensemble avec vous
monsieur le Président puisque nous
recevons dans une heure le président de
l'URSS et donc je vous propose peut-être
voilà de faire au moins une intervention
par groupe pour ceux qui le souhaitent
et s'il nous reste du temps bien sûr de
prendre les questions supplémentaires
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues donc nous avons le plaisir de
vous auditionner monsieur le Président
ce matin et ensuite monsieur Niel comme
je viens de le dire sur la réforme qui
est annoncée du contrôle et de la
recherche en matière de sûreté nucléaire
et de radioprotection à la suite du
conseil politique nucléaire qui s'est
tenu le 3 février sous l'égide du
président de la République il a d'abord
été annoncé que les activités
d'expertise de l'URSS rejoindraient la
SN et celle de la recherche Commissariat
à l'énergie atomique et aux énergies
alternatives finalement on nous annonce
que la SN engloberait toutes les
activités c'est beaucoup d'improvisation
pour des choses bien sérieuses une
déclaration d'intention de la ministre
chargée de l'énergie une lettre de
mission adressée par elle aux
responsables de ces trois organismes
donc à vous même ont ainsi été rendu
public le 8 février
ses responsables ont remis un plan
d'action le 20 février publieront et
vous publierez un rapport détaillé d'ici
juin cette réforme dont les contours
évoluent donc deux jours un jour
semble-t-il à susciter l'immois de
l'IRSN et celle du Parlement également
son conseil d'administration examiné une
motion le 16 février dernier alertant le
gouvernement sur les risques d'une
paralysie du système de contrôle et lui
rappelant que son expertise ne se limite
pas à la filière nucléaire mais s'étend
aux usages de la radioactivité dans les
domaines industriels médical et
militaires de plus son personnel à
engager c'est l'air du temps eu un
mouvement de grève le 20 février cette
réforme qui ne figurait pas initialement
dans le projet de loi nouveau nucléaire
a été présenté par le Gouvernement à
l'Assemblée nationale par le biais de
deux amendements le premier vise à
élargir les missions de la SN à
l'expertise la recherche et la
radioprotection à garantir l'accès à ses
agents aux informations nécessaires à
permettre le recours à des agents
publics comme privés et à instituer un
comité social l'administration le second
temps à transférer les contrats de
travail des agents de l'URSS il est
prévu que la réforme s'effectue jusqu'en
2024 dans ce contexte lopex
a fixé six gardes de fou après vous
avoir tous auditionné conserver un bloc
de compétences d'expertise et de
recherche de l'URSS au sein de la SN
maintenez une séparation entre les rôles
exécutif de contrôle et d'expertise et
ceux de la décision et du pilotage ainsi
que les garanties sur l'information la
transparence le dialogue avec la société
veillez à l'absence de monopole dans
l'expertise nucléaire instituer un
contrôle de l'Office sur cette réforme
est tirer les enseignements des systèmes
étrangers enfin inscrire cette réforme
dans une vision plus large s'appuyant
sur les capacités
pour notre commission monsieur le
Président cette réforme pose clairement
deux difficultés tant sur la méthode que
dans son contenu sur la méthode elle
intervient par voie d'amendement
gouvernementaux c'est je le dis
totalement irrespectueux du débat
parlementaire en général du travail
sénatorial en particulier car notre
assemblée forcé de légiférer dans
l'urgence sur ce texte y compris durant
la trêve des confiseurs fait aujourd'hui
face au risque d'être saisi sur un sujet
qui nous semble majeur c'est pour
conjurer ce risque que nous vous avons
souhaité vous entendre aujourd'hui de
surcroît une telle méthode et sous
optimale du point de vue de l'efficacité
des politiques publiques car ces
amendements n'ont évidemment pas fait
l'objet d'études d'impact et présente un
lien avec le texte récent à démontrer
devant le juge constitutionnel
concernant son contenu cette réforme
soulève au moins trois interrogations
est-il bien au porteur de procéder à une
telle réforme source de désorganisation
souvent à l'heure de la relance du
nucléaire qui suppose de prolonger les
réacteurs existants et d'en construire
de nouveau pourquoi prendre le risque
d'un stylet de la défiance de la part de
nos concitoyens d'autre part comment
garantir le maintien en bloc des
compétences de l'URSS qui sont
indispensables pour répondre aux besoins
croissants de contrôle induit par cette
relance je rappelle que l'IRSN dispose
1800 effectifs la SN de 500 surtout une
telle réforme est-elle de nature à
améliorer la sûreté nucléaire c'est bien
sûr la question principale que je
souhaitais vous poser ce matin je
rappelle que l'IRSN émet un avis public
sur les décisions de l'ASN ce qui permet
un dialogue entre expertise d'un côté et
contrôle de l'eau quel système
alternatif pourrait être envisagé afin
de ne pas zéroder ce dialogue voilà
pardon de séminaire un petit peu long
mais nous sommes évidemment très
attentif à ce qui se passe je vous
laisse répondre à ces questions
liminaires puis Daniel Gremillet vous
posera les premières questions ainsi que
mes collègues voilà monsieur le
président
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs de
nous recevoir aujourd'hui merci monsieur
le rapporteur d'être également présent
avec nous ce matin alors pour essayer de
répondre à un certain nombre de
questions vous venez de poser je
voudrais peut-être commencer en
redonnant un peu du sens à cette réforme
et comme vous l'avez parfaitement
souligné cette réforme s'inscrit donc
dans un moment très particulier de notre
décision en matière de politique
énergétique et notamment dans le cadre
d'une relance d'un programme nucléaire
sans précédent depuis plus d'une
vingtaine d'années et lorsque l'on
regarde
l'histoire du l'organisation du contrôle
de la sûreté et de l'expertise ou de la
recherche en France des grands
mouvements qui ont été réalisés dans
cette organisation vont toujours été à
des moments importants de décision en ce
qui concerne l'ambition nucléaire de
notre pays et également les événements
qui s'était produit tentent en termes
d'accident que en termes de retour
d'expérience sur ces accidents je dirais
simplement que il y a 50 ans que le
contrôle de la sûreté nucléaire a été
mise en place sous forme d'une
administration à service
d'administration et cela a été fait au
moment où le Premier ministre de
l'époque Pierre Mesmer a décidé en 1973
de lancer un programme électro-nucléaire
basé sur une technologie de réacteur à
eau sous pression américaine alors que
jusqu'à lors des technologies
développées en France étaient des
technologies graphiques gaz développé
par le CEA donc le fait qu'il y ait eu
cette décision avec un programme
extrêmement ambitieux qui a conduit à la
mise en place de 58 réacteurs en
plusieurs décennies à conduit à
réorganiser le contrôle de la sûreté
nucléaire et de la région protection qui
était à l'époque intégrée dans le CEA
donc le premier mouvement est lié à
cette décision tout ceci a au fil du
temps c'est bien sûr à conduit à des
renforcements à la fois du service de
l'État qui était en charge de contrôle
de la Sûreté Nucléaire puis ensuite de
la sûreté nucléaire et de la
radioprotection mais aussi de
l'expertise qui était toujours intégrée
au sein du CEA et c'est au début des
années 2000 qui a eu deux nouveaux une
impulsion avec la création d'irsn en
2002 et la création de l'ASN en tant
qu'autorité administrative indépendante
en 2006 et cette lors de sa cérémonie
des vœux de l'un des 2006 que le
président Chirac a annoncé en même temps
le lancement d'un programme nouveau
nucléaire c'était le programme EPR et la
constitution de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire indépendante sous forme d'ail
donc vous voyez bien à chaque fois qu'il
y a eu des impulsions fortes en matière
de stratégie de politique nucléaire il y
a eu une évolution dans l'organisation
du contrôle de la sûreté et de la
radioprotection nous sommes dans un
moment semblable aujourd'hui il y a
effectivement dans les mois à venir des
décisions importantes bien évidemment
dans lesquelles le Parlement jouera un
rôle fondamental qui sera le choix de
nouvelles orientations de politiques
énergétique et notamment de sa
composante nucléaire et donc il ne me
semble pas du tout illégitime après que
le gouvernement se soit penché sur la
manière d'accompagner ce cette nouvelle
politique si elle était décidée par un
renforcement de la filière nucléaire
qu'il s'interroge sur un renforcement du
contrôle de la Sûreté Nucléaire et
d'arbresection c'est en fait des choses
qui se font dans une réflexion
d'ensemble et qui sont assez logiques et
d'une certaine manière le modèle qui en
tout cas le modèle qui est en tête c'est
celui qui existe de manière le plus
répandue dans le monde
occidental en matière d'organisation du
contrôle de la Sûreté Nucléaire et
d'aratio protection ou finalement
l'expertise et le contrôle et la
décision sont intégrés dans une même
organisation c'est le cas aux États-Unis
c'est le Canada c'est le cas au Japon
donc nous ne sommes pas en train
d'inventer un modèle nous sommes en
train de regarder les meilleures
pratiques internationales pour pouvoir
nous interroger nous-mêmes tout va c'est
le gouvernement qui est posé cette
question sur la manière de faire le
système pour leur plus robuste plus
efficace et adapté aux enjeux sans
précédent face auxquels nous allons nous
trouver pas pendant les deux ou trois
prochaines années mais pendant plusieurs
décennies la nouvelle impulsion qui sont
prises en matière de politique
énergétique vont conduire à des charges
de travail et à des impulsions qui vont
durer plusieurs dizaines d'années donc
c'est une décision importante à un
moment qui va produire des effets qui
produira des effets sur plusieurs
dizaines d'années lorsque l'on parle de
construction de problèmes
électronucléaires se sont en
interacteurs qui vont durer 60 ans ils
vont être construits sur une période de
plusieurs dizaines d'années et quand on
parle de poursuite d'exploitation des
réacteurs actuels on ne s'interroge sur
60 ans au-delà de 60 ans ça veut dire
pour les réacteurs les plus récents plus
de 40 ans encore de durée de vie donc
voyez-vous on est dans un une
perspective historique d'organisation du
contrôle de la sûreté nucléaire et de la
radioprotection qui va durer longtemps
et qui doit être prise à un moment où
cette impulsion est organisée
la seule mission de la SN c'est la
protection des personnes et la
protection de l'environnement par
rapport à l'utilisation de des
rayonnements ionisants tant en ce qui
concerne des usages industriels comme la
production d'électroniculaire mais aussi
des usages en matière de santé en
matière industrielle donc c'est bien
l'ensemble du champ qui est couvert pour
avec deux organismes qui ont la même
raison d'être il y a pas un qui ne
regarde que la sûreté et l'autre qui
regarderait la surprise plus d'autres
intérêts non les deux organismes ne
regardent que le sujet de la le sûreté
et de la radioprotection et c'est
l'alignement sur le standard le plus
élevé alors cette situation elle est
différente de de ce qui existe quand on
parle de d'organisation dual je le mets
entre guillemets entre d'un côté
l'expertise et de l'autre côté la
décision c'est vrai qu'il y a ce type
d'organisation en France n'est pas
majoritaire mais elle existe et elle
existe lorsque l'expert est un expert
qui est indépendant du parce que c'est
le gouvernement qui prend la décision et
qui prend la décision en intégrant la
vie de l'expert sur un sujet donné et
puis d'autres intérêts c'est normal il
est le gouvernement nous ne sommes pas
dans cette configuration
l'autorité l'ASN est une autorité
indépendante du gouvernement donc il
s'agit de rapprocher deux entités qui
sont toutes deux avec la même raison
d'être qui ne regarde que la sûreté et
si on regarde les décisions qui ont été
prises par la SN ces dernières années où
les dernières dizaines d'années je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse dire que la SN a
été amenée à prendre d'autres intérêts
que la sûreté dans ses décisions donc
c'est le même intérêt et c'est une
manière d'avoir une renforcement du
contrôle de la sûreté je pense que le
contrôle de la sûreté et la confiance
dans le contrôle de la sûreté se sont
véritablement des biens communs et il
faut que la réforme qui sera mise en
place si elle est décidée renforce ce
bien commun
il n'y aura pas de confiance dans le
nucléaire s'il n'y a pas de confiance
dans le contrôle indépendant de la
sûreté et de la radioprotection et donc
ce choix de fusion avec le statut le
plus élevé le plus haut possible en
termes d'indépendance me semble être de
nature à renforcer le contrôle la
confiance pardon dans le contrôle de la
sûreté et ça ça me paraît très très
important à
exprimer alors par rapport à ces projets
bien évidemment de d'évolution il y a un
certain nombre de
conséquences qui qui pourrait me
semble-t-il
mener à démontrer que cette réforme va
dans le bon sens alors elle va dans le
bon sens et je voudrais signaler 6
points de mon point de vue alors le
premier c'est que cette réforme elle
comporte d'abord
je dirais un élément en efficacité
puisqu'elle permettrait si elle était
décidée bien évidemment de renforcer le
processus qui va de expertise jusqu'à la
décision en ayant un processus qui soit
intégré à l'image de ce qui existe à
l'étranger avec bien évidemment un
certain nombre de garde-fous et je pense
vous avez référence à la
recommandation de l'OPEX qu'il faut bien
évidemment les six recommandations des
prendre intégralement et donc il faut à
l'intérieur de l'organisation future si
elle est décidée mettre en place des
dispositifs et ça ça peut être fait à
travers le règlement intérieur par
exemple de la SN dans le cas d'une
concertation à réaliser faire en sorte
qu'il y ait des garde-fous pour que les
différentes étapes soient effectivement
séparées et que l'étape en amont
d'instruction qui est une instruction
complexe qui comporte de l'instruction
technique qui comporte de l'instruction
réglementaire les décisions que nous
prenons sont peuvent être attaqués
juridiquement il faut une expertise
réglementaire cette expertise
réglementaire elle est à la SN
l'expertise technique elle est en partie
à la scène mais en partie aussi à la SN
donc on voit bien qu'il y a une espèce
de fragmentation aujourd'hui dans les
termes d'expertise et le fait d'avoir
l'ensemble de ces expertises sous j'ai
le même ombrelle permet d'avoir une plus
grande fluidité une plus grande
efficacité dans la phase d'instruction
qui doit rester bien vivant séparé de la
décision lorsque cette décision est
prise sur les sujets à plus fort en jeu
par le collège de la SN je pense que ça
ce sont des garanties qu'on peut tout à
fait tout à fait affirmé et développé je
pense que cette organisation ramassée
est aussi une organisation qui permet de
faire face de manière plus efficace aux
besoins nouveaux de compétences
techniques je m'explique je me souviens
que dans cette salle nous avons il y a
quelques mois madame la Présidente
évoquait les enjeux du nouveau nucléaire
et je me souviens que nous avons parlé
des SMS nous avons aujourd'hui plusieurs
projets de SMR en France qui commence à
émerger bien sûr il y a le projet d'EDF
qui est sur une technologie connue qui
ne pose pas de difficultés en matière de
compétence pour nous pour l'URSS et pour
les exploitants mais nous avons aussi
quatre projets sur des technologies qui
aujourd'hui n'existent pas pour
lesquelles il y a pas la compétence ni à
la scène ni à lire donc il va falloir
renforcer ses compétences il va falloir
les acquérir si ces projets
d'Amr de réacteurs innovants
émergé je pense que c'est bien
l'intention de le faire il va falloir
renforcer les compétences avoir une
structure ramassée pour avoir cette
compétences qui sont nécessaires c'est
certainement plus efficace que de
renforcer les deux structures avec les
compétences qui sont nécessaires donc je
pense qu'il y a à travers cet exemple il
y a un besoin par rapport aux nouveaux
nucléaire et il y aura plein de sujets
nouveaux que nous n'avons pas identifié
aujourd'hui ce sera plus efficace de
dire on renforce la structure la
structure ramassée la structure
fusionnée plutôt que de disperser les
compétences nouvelles qu'il faudrait
avoir pour pouvoir gérer ce sujet
je pense que une structure ramassée est
aussi un bon moyen de mieux gérer les
priorités aujourd'hui on est quand on
évalue la somme de travail que nous
aurons devant nous dans les 20 années
qui viennent en termes d'instruction
c'est considérable c'est c'est inconnu
de nombreuses années il va falloir
renforcer les équipes d'ailleurs c'est
clairement dit dans les le projet de loi
qui aura effectivement plusieurs études
qui vont être faites qui vont associer
le Parlement pour pouvoir évaluer quels
sont les renforts dont nous avons besoin
donc il faut avoir un souci d'efficacité
pour renforcer l'ensemble des structures
des composantes et bien évidemment il me
semble que c'est ce renforcement devra
aussi être accompagné dans une gestion
des priorités il y a un certain nombre
d'événements qui sont parfois des
événements inattendus qui se produisent
qui nous qui consiste à réorienter le
programme à la fois d'instruction et de
décision ça arrive chaque jour et c'est
normal on est face à une industrie qui
évolue chaque jour il faut qu'on ait de
la souplesse aujourd'hui c'est c'est pas
souple lorsque l'on a deux entités ce
sera beaucoup plus facile lorsqu'il y en
aura que
quatrième argument aujourd'hui nous
avons un rôle fondamental qui est celui
d'appui du gouvernement en situation
d'urgence cette appui aujourd'hui il est
séquencé il est organisé de telle
manière que dans un premier temps l'IRSN
sur la base des informations concernant
l'événement des informations données par
l'exploitant fait une évaluation de la
situation et ce projet sur la manière
dont cette situation va évoluer ça c'est
le rôle de l'expertise technique le
résultat de cette expertise est donné à
l'ASM qui a la mission et c'est l'ASM
qu'il a de conseiller le gouvernement en
cellule interministériale de crise face
au président au Premier ministre de dire
mais finalement voilà ce que nous vous
proposons pour la suite ce système
séquencé nous le testons à l'occasion
des exercices et on voit bien que il est
rigide d'avoir un système séquencé il
faut qu'il y ait un système unique qu'on
soit capable d'avoir une réponse unique
face à une situation de crise cela ça le
permettra d'avoir cette organisation
nouvelle pardon si elle était
vous avez cinquième point vous avez
beaucoup un peu insisté et je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec vous l'OPEX Lady
d'ailleurs sur la nécessité de conserver
un haut niveau de transparence
d'information d'associations du public
et je dirais de d'ouverture à la société
c'est ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas une organisation qui est
ouverte vers la société et puis une
autre qui ne saurait moins ce n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui nous travaillons tous
les jours avec les clips les clés ce
sont nos interlocuteurs de terrain et je
sais qu'au sein de cet ensemble Sénat
vous êtes très attaché à cette
représentation territoriale parce que
nous sommes la seule autorité
administrative indépendante ayant un
réseau territorial nous avons 11
divisions elles seront proches des
installations nucléaires elles seront
proches des clients ce n'est pas le cas
d'irsn on a un réseau territorial donc
cette proximité territoriale avec les
clips avec le réseau de l'ampli moi-même
je préside chaque année et nous
co-organisons avec l'ampli la conférence
annuelle des clients ça existe c'est il
y a aucune raison de de
l'affai bien évidemment tout ce qui est
fait par l'IRSN est aussi extrêmement
important et je crois et c'est une des
missions qui nous a été confiée par le
Premier ministre qu'en termes de
renforcement de la culture de la sûreté
et de la radioprotection des populations
on aura la possibilité d'additionner à
la fois les ressources de l'ASS et les
ressources de dégraissn pour renforcer
cette connaissance des risques et des
comportements des bons comportements à
avoir en cas d'accident ça c'est une
mission que le premier ministre a confié
à la SN en tant que président d'un
comité qui s'appelle le CODIRPA donc
voyez-vous l'ouverture de la société
pour moi ce n'est pas un sujet nous
allons prendre les meilleures pratiques
qui existent dans les deux organismes et
je pense qu'on aura la manière les
moyens de consolider cette approche on
pourra faire encore plus en rassemblant
les forces donc il me semble vraiment il
y a pas de d'appréhension à avoir sur
cette nécessité absolue d'ouverture à la
société de transparence et d'information
et dans un sens de développement de la
culture de sûreté et je termine par le
sixième point qui me paraît aussi tout à
fait importante aujourd'hui l'IRSN comme
la SN sont deux entités qui sont
reconnues au niveau international et
notre reconnaissance elle est
essentiellement fondée par le poids de
la du parc nucléaire en France c'est
c'est clair que lorsque l'on discute
avec nos homologues américains ou
japonais le fait que l'on nous ayons 56
réacteurs en exploitation que nous ayons
de la désinstallations sur la totalité
du cycle du combustible que l'on a une
politique de gestion des déchets qui
soient exemplaires et reconnus au niveau
international fait que nous avons une
influence nous sommes écoutés parce que
nous avons nous sommes adossés à une
expérience nucléaire de longue date qui
est de très haut niveau mais nous avons
en fait une action qui est qui est
dispersé puisqu'il y a d'un côté la SN
qui a ses relations avec les homologues
à l'étranger et de l'autre côté
l'irsl qui a aussi des relations avec
nos propres hom parce que nos homologues
ils ont l'expertise et la décision qui
est intégrée eux ils ont tout nous on
est séparés et trop on a un contact l'un
et l'autre avec les mêmes personnes ça
n'a pas beaucoup de sens donc je pense
qu'on renforcera également la mettre
notre influence et la manière dont nous
pourrons avoir les relations avec nos
plus grands homologues à l'étranger dans
une période cruciale pourquoi il est
crucial il y a aujourd'hui entre 30 et
40 pays dans le monde qui envisagent qui
ne sont pas nucléarisés et qui
envisagent de s'ouvrir au nucléaire pour
pouvoir répondre bien sûr à l'urgence
climatique ces pays ont besoin
d'assistance ils n'ont pas
d'infrastructures de contrôle de la
sûreté ni d'expertise pouvoir
accompagner éventuellement la conquête
par l'industrie française on est là on
n'est pas là pour pour développer
l'industrie mais accompagner des
mouvements de l'industrie française à
l'étranger pour dire à nos homologues
nous nous sommes en situation de pouvoir
vous apporter un appui dans le
développement de votre infrastructure de
contrôle et expertise ça me semble
plutôt un gage d'efficacité renforcement
donc voyez-vous madame la présidente
Madame et messieurs je pense qu'il y a
un certain nombre d'éléments qui
seraient la conséquence de cette réforme
si bien sûr elle était votée décidée par
le pendant qui sont favorables au
renforcement à la fois de la confiance
et leur renforcement de l'efficacité
dans le contrôle de la sûreté nucléaire
et de la radioprotection
très bien merci monsieur le Président je
vais passer la parole à Daniel grimillet
qui va vous poser ces questions comme
président de du groupe d'études
d'énergie
oui merci
le Président Monsieur le Directeur
général Michel collègues
je partage tout à fait des propos
indiqués par notre président sur le
mépris du parlementaire et les
inquiétudes sur la sûreté nucléaire
cette réforme présentée dans le cadre
d'amendement gouvernementaux peut-être
une source de défiance quelle que soit
d'ailleurs son impact réel je le déplore
car il faut au contraire bâtir la
relance du nucléaire sur la confiance
mais aussi sur l'anticipation et non la
précipitation c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons inscrit dans le
projet de loi de nouveau-nucléaire
plusieurs dispositions en faveur de la
Sûreté Nucléaire elle vise à intégrer la
résilience au changement climatique dans
la démonstration de sûreté des réacteurs
et aussi la cyberse résilience dans leur
protection contre les actes de
malveillance prendre en compte les
risques de submersion et d'inondation
est de recul du trait de côte dès
l'attribution des concessions maritimes
la mission de l'URSS autant d'arguments
et de propositions qui ne semblent plus
avoir cours aujourd'hui plus encore
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous pensez de
la réforme proposée par le gouvernement
le Premier amendement présenté par lui
sur la consolidation des attributions de
la SN vous paraît-il adapté reprend-il
bien l'ensemble des missions de l'URSS
et qu'en est-il du second amendement sur
les transferts de personnels du grsn
vous pouvez vous nous assurer que ces
effectifs seront bien reconduits avec
des niveaux de rémunération et des
conditions de travail similaires jusqu'à
quand cet aileron s'est transfert et
quel sera l'effort de formation enfin je
voudrais savoir comment vous comptez
répondre aux recommandations de l'OPEX
dans quel schéma seront assurés les
missions d'expertise et de contrôle
entendez-vous institué excusez-moi
expression une muraille de Chine entre
ses activités par ailleurs comment
seront garanties le dialogue entre la
société et l'absence de monopole dans
l'expertise nucléaire enfin dans quelle
mesure et sur quel point intégrerez vous
le retour d'expérience des systèmes
intégrés étrangers et puis une question
complémentaire avec l'actualité quel est
le point de vue de la SN sur le
phénomène de corrosion sous contrainte
quid de la fissure plus importante que
prévu observer à Pandi remettait en
cause et perspectives de disponibilité
et de recettes du parc existant voilà
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues les
questions que je souhaitais vous poser
merci Daniel en complément j'ai demandé
à Pascal Martin qui était le rapporteur
pour avis et de la commission du
développement durable du projet de loi
d'accélération nucléaire merci madame la
Présidente déjà merci de m'avoir convié
à cette audition monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur général je
souhaite à mon tour vous interroger sur
deux points particuliers de ce projet de
réforme de la Sûreté Nucléaire
premièrement je souhaite évoquer les
éventuels difficultés opérationnelles de
la réorganisation comme l'ont récemment
souligné dans une tribune du journal Le
Monde les anciens présidents de l'OPEX
l'ASN et l'IRSN sont deux organismes de
taille différente l'IRSN vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le Président compte
environ plus de 1700 collaborateurs et
la SN un peu moins de 600 agents en
incluant les effectifs déconcentrés
considérez-vous que l'ASN dispose des
ressources nécessaires pour organiser je
mets tout ça entre guillemets
l'absorption d'un organisme
considérablement plus important en
termes d'effectif comment l'autorité se
prépare-t-elle aujourd'hui à cette
éventualité
ma deuxième question est Daniel
Gremillet l'a évoqué donc je vais aller
rapidement porte plus généralement sur
l'état des relations entre la SN et
l'URSS en 2021 nous avions auditionné
monsieur Niel
à la Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire dans le cadre de l'article 13
de la Constitution suite à sa nomination
j'avais alors interrogé monsieur Niel
sur les relations entre l'ASN et l'IRSN
il nous avait présenté ses relations
comme étant selon ces mots très dense et
structuré et avait mentionné je le cite
toujours une approbation complète et
sans réserve par la scène du travail de
l'ISSN il ne semblait donc pas que la
dualité d'organisation réduisait la
fluidité des décisions en matière de
sûreté nucléaire
pourtant le renforcement de la fluidité
est l'un des arguments avancés pour
justifier cette fusion partagez-vous
monsieur le Président le constat que
faisait et Monsieur Niel en 2021
concernant cette fluidité des relations
entre les deux organismes la situation
a-t-elle évolué durant ces deux
dernières années merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup je voulais c'est répondre
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur général bien sûr si vous
voulez prendre la parole
merci merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le rapporteur merci monsieur le
sénateur Martin
[Musique]
je vais effectivement répondre à ces
questions je laisserai Olivier egyptard
et prendre sur le sujet
lié à la séparation de l'expertise et de
la décision alors qu'est-ce qui justifie
un changement qui pourrait apparaître
comme étant un changement de position de
la SA dans le vous-même vous avez cité
des dates en fait il y a effectivement
eu des prises de position 2014 2015 ou
2016 qui correspondait au contexte de
l'époque on est je l'ai dit dans mon
intervention dans un contexte
complètement nouveau personne
n'imaginait encore il y a 2 ans que l'on
débattrait d'un programme électronique
clair aussi ambitieux qu'on se poserait
la question de la poursuite
d'exploitation de réacteurs jusqu'à 60
ans voire au-delà et qu'on
s'interrogerait sur le
devenir de l'industrie du cycle du
combustible donc il y a un contexte
différent et je pense qu'on ne peut pas
le négliger sur le fait que il faut se
mettre en ordre il faut d'une certaine
manière se mettre en ordre comme je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure la filière elle-même
se met en ordre ça serait assez
illogique qui est d'un côté une décision
de mobilisation de la totalité des
ressources parce qu'il y aura un besoin
de compétences exceptionnelle dans la
filière plus clair et que l'on ne
s'interroge pas sur la manière de faire
une approche similaire en ce qui
concerne le contrôle de la sûreté
nucléaire et de la radio protection et
je l'ai dit il y a un élément qui est
favorable et qui est pas à négliger
c'est le fait que nous avons la même
raison d'être nous faisons la même chose
avec le même avec le même objectif donc
rapprochez deux entités qui ont la même
qui ont la même raison d'être c'est me
semble-t-il quelque chose de tout à fait
envisageable si la réforme bien sûr est
décidée donc voilà en ce qui concerne
cette ce premier point ensuite vous
évoquez les questions de périmètre de
mission vous avez évoqué la cyber
résilience qui était effectivement une
des propositions du du Sénat à l'issue
de la première lecture renforcer le
texte sur la cyber résilience et vous
m'avez posé la question du périmètre
plus générale de la future réforme en
termes de mission donc moi je voudrais
dire qu'il y a il y a un point qui
correspond à des sujets que nous avons
évoqué à plusieurs reprises qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas présent dans le
texte du Gouvernement c'est la question
de la sécurité des installations
nucléaires civiles nous avons à
plusieurs reprises indiquées que l'ASN
estimait là encore au vu de retour
d'expérience internationale tous nos
homologues à l'étranger pour les
installations du père civile ont en
charge la Sûreté Nucléaire ce que nous
faisons mais aussi la sécurité c'est
quoi la sécurité c'est la lutte contre
les actes de malveillance bien sûr il y
a la cybersécurité dedans mais il y a
d'autres choses il y a l'intrusion etc
parce que c'est un petit moment lié
quand on regarde bien évidemment le
dimensionnement d'une installation
nucléaire et on l'a on a dimensionne par
rapport au risque accidentel mais aussi
par rapport au risque d'agression un
risque d'agression malveillante et je
pense c'est aussi un point que j'avais
cité ici madame la Présidente lors de la
table ronde sur le nouveau nucléaire que
ce sujet va être particulièrement
important pour les SMR dès lors que les
SMR ne seront pas installés sur les
sites nucléaires actuels parce que si on
veut véritablement avoir un effet
et de développement il va falloir les
mettre ailleurs et ben il y aura
ailleurs les sujets qui se poseront en
termes de sécurité et de sûreté on ne
peut pas imaginer la sécurité d'une
petite installation de la même manière
d'une grosse avec des barbelés des
gendarmes etc ce n'est pas la même chose
donc je pense qu'il y a il y a là un
manque dans le projet qui vous est
proposé qui vous sera proposé en tout
cas qui est proposé au Parlement il y a
dans la définition des missions que
l'ASN pourrait accueillir et qui sont
aujourd'hui exercés par l'IRSN il y a la
mission de dans le domaine de
l'expertise liée à la sécurité des
installations civiles qui n'est pas
explicitement présente et il me semble
qu'il faudrait l'ajouter à l'ensemble
des missions qui seraient transférées de
l'IRSN à la SN c'est bien une mission
d'expertise c'est à dire qu'il y a
toujours une autorité de de sécurité
mais la mission d'expertise il va
conserver et ça permet d'avoir un niveau
homogène entre
l'ensemble des installations sur un
certain nombre de sujets transversaux
donc voilà moi le point en ce qui
concerne le périmètre qui me semble le
plus le plus important le reste du
périmètre me semble tout à fait
satisfaisant même s'il y a quelques
imprécisions dans le texte qu'il faudra
corriger mais je pense que ce n'est pas
une difficulté les recommandations de
l'OPEX je l'ai dit tout à l'heure pour
moi elles sont parfaitement appropriées
il faut absolument les reprendre définir
la manière de les reprendre notamment
dans le règlement intérieur de la SN et
il faut laisser à la SN le soin de les
intégrer la SN est une autorité
indépendante le Parlement lui donne et
c'est normal les objectifs qu'ils
souhaitent atteindre et c'est la SN qui
définit les moyens en tant qu'autorité
indépendante je pense qu'il faut faire
attention à ne pas aller trop loin dans
le texte législatif sur la définition
des moyens mais en revanche définir des
objectifs qui ensuite peuvent être
proposés par la SN
les relations avec la société civile je
l'ai dit tout large je n'y reviens pas
bien évidemment c'est ça me paraît
absolument fondamental de l'entretenir
et ce n'est pas le ce n'est pas pour moi
un sujet difficulté opérationnelle de la
de la fusion alors vous avez raison vous
avez donné des chiffres ils sont exacts
encore faut-il bien voir le périmètre
des missions peut-être ça peut changer
la marche c'est l'ordre de grandeur
bon aujourd'hui nous avons de bonnes
relations des relations qui sont comme
le disait Jean-Christophe Niel lors de
son audition qui sont des relations
techniques de haut niveau il n'y a pas
de il n'y a pas de difficulté entre des
experts techniques de l'ASN on en a et
puis les experts techniques de la SN là
encore c'est un élément qui me semble
favorable à réaliser une fusion même si
elle apparaît disproportionnée en nombre
c'est une fusion c'est que on a la même
raison d'être et on travaille depuis
longtemps ensemble les équipes se
connaissent bien s'apprécient elles ont
de bonnes relations donc c'est voilà je
le prendrai plutôt de cette nature là il
faut pas le voir comme étant des
difficultés l'effet des nombres c'est
que en fait on se connaît bien et on
travaille ensemble et on a même la même
raison d'être donc et quand on compare
le nouvel ensemble par rapport au à deux
homologues à l'étranger ça reste du même
ordre grandeur il y a 2700 personnes à
la NRC aux États-Unis donc je dirais que
voilà pour faire cela y compris la
recherche tu restes intégrée ça vous
l'avez souligné madame la Présidente
c'est une décision qui a été prise dans
un deuxième temps par le gouvernement et
qui équival dans le bon sens donc voilà
donc moi me semble que il y a
effectivement des points de vigilance il
y a les recommandations de l'OPEX qui
font intégralement reprendre il y a des
objectifs qui doivent être définis par
le Parlement et nous devons-nous avoir
le choix des moyens au niveau de la
scène en concertation puisqu'on doit
rapporter nous-mêmes on rapporte
nous-mêmes régulièrement à l’opex on
rapporte au Parlement on aura toute la
possibilité de rapporter ce que nous
ferons mais laissons à la SN le soin de
définir la manière et de proposer la
manière de s'organiser une fois que les
objectifs ont été arrêtés dans la loi
je raconterai sur la corrosion sous
contrat d'après mais je vais avoir une
certaine cohérence je vais laisser
Olivier répondre sur la question du donc
oui de séparation entre expertise et
décision peut-être simplement un
commentaire sur le terme dual à titre
personnel je le trouve trompeur parce
que finalement dual c'est deux et ça
peut laisser penser qu'il y a deux
autorités c'est évidemment pas le cas il
y a une autorité en charge du contrôle
et et qui dispose des pouvoirs de prise
de décision il y a un appui technique
c'est comme ça que ça s'appelle
d'ailleurs à l'étranger n'appui
technique qui qui intervient sur demande
de l'autorité et qui n'est pas si j'ose
dire suis génériste enfin qui qui est
saisi par l'autorité et qui et qui
répond à des à des demandes de celle-ci
et donc il y a pas dans le dispositif y
compris actuel une symétrie
entre entre les deux entre les deux
organismes alors une fois qu'on a dit ça
je confirme ce que je disais Bernard
drosuc les relations entre les équipes
de l'ASN et de l'IRSN sont excellentes
ce sont effectivement des personnels qui
travaillent de longue date main dans la
main sur les mêmes sujets ils ouvrent
les mêmes dossiers ils participent au
même réunion avec les exploitants et
c'est là que j'en viens à la question de
la séparation finalement entre expertise
décision je pense qu'il a aussi il faut
se garder de tout contre sens sur ce sur
ce sujet
il y a pas de muraille de Chine entre
les deux il y a il y a un continuum il y
a un quantième au sens où
effectivement il n'y a pas d'un côté et
c'est heureux des experts à l'IRSN qui
travaillent dans l'ignorance des
conséquences des avis qu'il rédigent
vous pensez bien que quand Nagi est
signé par l'IRSN évidemment que les
conséquences de cet avis
sur
les
la mise en oeuvre par les industriels
des recommandations faites et peser
ça n'aurait évidemment pas de sens
d'imaginer que ce travail est fait
effectivement en méconnaissance totale
des réalités industrielles
et puis de notre côté à la SN des
personnes qui au contraire finalement
seraient dans la discussion la
négociation avec les industriels c'est
pas du tout comme ça que ça marche il y
a un dialogue technique approfondi
auquel participe aujourd'hui d'un côté
et du même côté d'ailleurs les
personnels de la SN et de l'IRSN et de
l'autre les industriels
nous sommes du même côté avec l'IRSN
bien entendu dans ce dialogue technique
et et
ce que je souligner aussi c'est que
il n'y a il n'y a pas dans les documents
de référence internationaux dans les
dans les recommandations en tout cas pas
dans celles qui servent aux revues par
les Pères dont nous bénéficions
régulièrement et d'ailleurs nous allons
en accueillir une dans un peu moins d'un
an une revue dite irrs de la IEA qui
examine la manière dont nous travaillons
nous
ASN et IRSN organisme de contrôle nous
allons être audité par nos pères et dans
les référentiels qui sont utilisés par
ces audits dans ces audits il n'y a pas
d'exigence de séparation de l'expertise
et de la décision il y a des exigences
sur le fait que
l'analyse technique l'examen technique
doit disposer des compétences
nécessaires des moyens nécessaires du
temps nécessaire
il y a des exigences naturellement mais
elles sont déjà évidemment
remplis satisfaite d'indépendance entre
les organismes qui contrôlent d'une part
et ceux d'autres parts qui font la
politique énergétique ou qui est
naturellement exploite les installations
et donc si murailles de Chine il y a au
sein du d'une organisation
de contrôle c'est éventuellement entre
des gens qui sont en charge de prendre
des décisions et d'autres qui au sein de
laboratoire de recherche utilisent des
radioéléments et effectivement doivent
les utiliser eux aussi dans le respect
des règles de sûreté nucléaire et de
renexion ce sont les seuls murailles de
Chine il n'y a pas encore une fois dans
les référentiels de la UEA utilisé pour
ces audits d'exigences de séparation et
et d'autant moins encore une fois que
c'est la bonne preuve plusieurs
autorités et pas des moindres
rassemblent les les mêmes compétences en
leur sein
voilà donc je pense que effectivement
c'est important de de bien de bien
clarifier ce point
je pense que ça peut permettre aussi de
d'apaiser des des inquiétudes qui ont pu
effectivement se faire jour ça et là il
y a absolument pas dans cette éventuelle
réunion si elle va jusqu'à son terme de
régression de ce point de vue c'est je
veux vraiment le dire de façon très
claire et il n'y a pas non plus l'idée
parce que c'est peut-être aussi ça qui
plane en filigrane que l'IRSN est une
espèce de contre-pouvoir à la SN c'est
réellement pas l'esprit dans lequel
je pense le système a été pensé par
vous-même et vos prédécesseurs et je
pense et en tout cas ce que je peux dire
c'est ce que c'est pas du tout en tout
cas au plan pratique la manière dont ça
se passe aujourd'hui
avant de répondre peut-être c'est un
complément parce que ça me paraît
effectivement un point vraiment de
fixation très important il y a
effectivement vous l'avez rappelé un
certain nombre de déclarations qui
mettent comme principe la séparation
entre l'expertise et la décision au sein
de deux structures juridiques
différentes c'est faux non seulement
c'est faux par rapport au standard
internationaux mais ça n'aime pas la
réalité en France
comme j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure en
fait il y a eu la création des des
agences notamment dans le domaine
sanitaire suite à des événements qui
avaient été effectivement dramatique au
début des années 2000 où il y avait eu
une décision du gouvernement qui ne
s'appuyait pas sur une expertise
indépendante et donc c'est ce qui a été
fait mais parce que la décision était
prise par le gouvernement qui avait à
prendre en compte tous les intérêts ce
n'est pas le cas dans la réforme que
nous disons nous sommes indépendants du
gouvernement la SN est une autorité
indépendante et nous avons la même
raison d'être et même en France dans le
domaine sanitaire aujourd'hui la
situation est bien plus nuancée que ce
que l'on vous dit par exemple lances qui
est une agence et est aussi une agence
qui fait l'expertise et la décision dans
un certain nombre de domaines qui sont
dans ces règles donc même à l'intérieur
du panorama français ou cette dualité
alors c'est dans la règle je suis désolé
de
très bien alors je reviens sur la cesse
donc la CSC vous avez raison il y a eu
un élément nouveau qui ces dernières
semaines qui est la découverte d'une
fissuration de corrosion sous contrainte
sur un des circuits du réacteur de panic
1 qui a une taille très importante
puisque la fissuration elle fait 23 mm
pour une épaisseur totale qui en fait 27
c'est à dire il reste 4 mm d'épaisseur
donc la CSC nous l'avons dit je l'ai dit
à plusieurs reprises c'est un sujet
sérieux c'est pas des microfissures
quand il reste que 4 kill mm sur une
épaisseur de 27 ça pose problème alors
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé jusqu'à
présent et j'avais eu l'occasion de le
présenter moi de lepex et bien il y a eu
effectivement ce phénomène qui est
apparu sur un certain nombre de
réacteurs il y a eu un travail très
responsable et très très engageant très
engagé pardon de la part de d'EDF qui a
permis en quelques mois d'avoir
suffisamment d'expertise pour comprendre
et expliquer le phénomène qui se
produisait et pouvoir prioriser les
actions sur le parc nucléaire ça ça a
été fait au premier semestre
2022 et la raison fondamentale sur
lequel il n'y a pas de débat entre les
experts même s'il y a toujours des
raisons périphériques c'est que c'est la
géométrie des lignes qui a conduit à
développer un phénomène de corrosion
sous contrainte et cette géométrie des
lignes se retrouve sur les réacteurs les
plus récents c'est pas un phénomène de
vieillissement ces réacteurs les plus
récents qui ont 20 ans sont plus
affectés que les réacteurs de 900 MW qui
sont les plus anciens parce que la
géométrie des lignes n'est pas la même
sur les 900 et quand on me dit on
comprend pas en France on trouve ça mais
aux États-Unis on en trouve rien mais
c'est normal les réacteurs qui sont aux
États-Unis sont de conception
identiques à nos réacteurs de 900
mégawatts c'est à dire finalement ce sur
lequel nous-mêmes on en a pas trouvé de
corrosion sous contrainte en France donc
c'est logique qui en est pas aux
États-Unis c'est pas parce qu'on est
plus sévère c'est pas parce qu'on met
des techniques de contrôle enfin 3 mm de
de de filassuration sur 27 c'est sérieux
donc voilà donc jusqu'à présent
sur cette explication qui justifiait la
stratégie de priorisation d'ef sur 16
réacteurs par rapport à l'ensemble du
parc 16 sur 56 4 réacteurs N4 les plus
récents et 12 réacteurs le phénomène qui
est apparu là qui a été détecté et
différent c'est en fait une soudure qui
a été doublement réparée et dont
l'alignement a été forcé l'alignement
des tuyauteries avant de faire la
soudure ont été forcés parce que
finalement le montage d'une tuyauterie
se fait de proche en proche quand on est
sur site et à la fin il y a la soudure
finale et et s'il y a eu des écarts
d'ajustement à la fin ça c'est pas face
à face il y a une approche qui n'est pas
acceptable il y a eu qui a consisté un
peu à forcer les Tuileries pour les
aligner pour les souder et il y a eu sur
cette soudure des défauts qui ont
conduit à faire une deuxième réparation
donc on est sur un point singulier on
n'est pas sur une explication générique
c'est la géométrie de des réacteurs qui
posent problème ça veut pas dire que
cette ce défaut ne peut pas apparaître
ailleurs donc ce que nous sommes en
train de faire avec EDF et nous avons
demandé à EDF de faire rapidement c'est
d'identifier les casse semblables qui
pourraient exister sur les autres
réacteurs du parc nucléaire pour pouvoir
aller contrôler ses soudures donc on va
faire un traitement spécifique on a mis
la pression surf pour une définition une
évolution de la stratégie du contrôle ça
supprime pas la stratégie initiale qui
est liée à un sujet générique la
géométrie des lignes mais ça rajoute un
point particulier lorsqu'il y a eu des
réparations qui ont été faites de cette
nature voilà la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes
très bien merci beaucoup je vais donner
la parole à chaque groupe politique on
va commencer par Bernard buis ensuite
Daniel salmon merci président j'avais
deux questions mais la première vous
avez répondu puisqu'elle portait sur la
séparation fonctionnelle entre
l'émission de contrôle d'expertise et le
mécanisme de décision la seconde
question porte sur les préconisations de
l'OPEX vous avez dit qu'il fallait les
reprendre pourquoi ne souhaitez ou pas
qu'elle soit reprise dans la loi je suis
pas très bien compris merci on va
prendre de toutes les questions à
Monsieur le Président si vous en êtes
d'accord Daniel salmon merci Bernard
merci madame le Président Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Directeur je vais
revenir juste sur la Genèse nous avons
tous été surpris ici de cette annonce
puisque à rien n'avait filtré on avait
plutôt l'idée que ce système dual il est
présenté comme soit comme cela était une
peut-être une originalité française mais
qui justement confortait la sûreté et
donc sur la méthode comme la souligner
Daniel Grémillet il y a un sujet il y a
un réel sujet le Parlement a été
complètement décédé on passe par un
amendement alors que la loi accélération
du nucléaire est déjà passé au Sénat ça
survient entre les deux pouvez-vous nous
dire déjà
quel est l'origine quelle est la demande
est-ce que c'est l'exécutif qui a fait
cette demande ou est-ce que tout est
parti de de l'ASN on aimerait bien
savoir un petit peu comment comment cela
s'est produit effectivement nous jamais
eu l'idée qu'il y avait une symétrie
entre la SN du RSN ça nous est jamais
passé par l'esprit justement le système
dual c'est d'avoir d'un côté expertise
recherche et de l'autre côté plutôt la
décision et le contrôle donc voilà c'est
quelque chose qui semblait faire la
force de la sûreté du nucléaire français
et là et bien on remet tout ça en cause
parliez de confiance je crois que voilà
effectivement on entre dans une période
de défiance vous avez fait un
rapprochement avec les changements de
technologie graphique gaz et après aux
pressurisé mais là si j'ai bien compris
mais on passe d'un EPR un EPR 2 il y a
pas de changement de technologie donc on
est un peu on n'est pas dans ces ce
paradigme là
voilà je voudrais simplement savoir
comment cela va se passer puisque on
sent que les relations étaient bonnes
anti RSN et la SN et j'ai l'impression
qu'elles sont beaucoup moins bonnes
aujourd'hui donc pour avoir une fusion
il aurait été plutôt intéressant d'avoir
deux entités qui avaient une volonté de
fusionner ce qui n'est pas du tout le
cas donc
maintenant vous allez pouvez-vous nous
expliquer comment cela va se passer et
on parle de remettre des barrières pour
avoir une vraie indépendance
alors on avait deux entités qui étaient
bien séparées on va remettre tout ça
dans une et on va remettre des barrières
j'ai du mal à comprendre la logique de
tout cela merci
Daniel pardon de presser tout le monde
un peu mais Franck Menonville la
présidente monsieur le Président je suis
sénateur de la Meuse donc un des deux
départements qui porte le projet sigo
notamment et moi ce que je voudrais dire
à cet instant c'est c'est vraiment le
bon vous nous avez plutôt moi j'ai
trouvé vos propos bien évidemment
convaincant sur la
sur l'aspect organisationnel et vos
ambitions
néanmoins et je rebondis sur mes
propos de Daniel salmon c'est vrai que
c'est un sujet tellement
sensible
la filière nucléaire qui repose sur
vraiment une notion bien évidemment de
sécurité que la France maîtrise et que
vous vous maîtrisez
parfaitement mais aussi de confiance
envers
de nos de nos concitoyens et c'est pour
cela que voir arriver
ce sujet au travers
voir arriver ce sujet un sujet aussi
important par voie d'amendement alors
même que il y a quelques semaines vous
avons traité du projet de loi dans
relance du nucléaire nous nous avons
aussi l'OPEX ça nous semble bien
évidemment
finalement contre contre-productif alors
la préconiser les préconisations de
l'OPEX je pense qu'il est important de
les intégrer et les intégrer comme la du
Bernard dans la loi et moi ma question
c'est aussi comment comptez-vous quelles
sont vos aussi vos ambitions et vos
l'orientation de de l'ASN pour
anticiper accompagner les nouveaux
risques émergents que nous avons liés à
la cybersécurité à la
j'allais dire à la géopolitique actuelle
mais aussi au risque climatique
merci Franck Franck montoger
mettant micro
je ne sais pas si vous vous si vous
partagez mais je pense que ce qui fait
l'intégrité scientifique parce que c'est
de ça dont il s'agit aussi ce sont les
personnes et leur liberté de penser
et
les structures dans lesquelles ils
évoluent ils travaillent
au-delà de la procédure législative pour
le moins de surprenantes qui a été
choisie par le gouvernement une fois de
plus si j'ose dire pour introduire ce ce
projet je note on note que la Cour des
comptes dans un rapport à considérer que
la séparation finalement actuelle était
était justifiée par cette dualité
complémentarité qui a été qui a été
évoquée donc voilà c'est un point de vue
personnellement je n'ai pas bien compris
sur quelle base de proposition vous
garantiriez
l'indépendance et la liberté des
personnels de l'URSS qui seraient donc
intégrées dans l'ASN et comment c'est
tout aussi important vous en feriez la
preuve de cette independance liberté en
direction des populations dont vous
aviez dit
l'importance qu'il y avait effectivement
à communiquer avec elle à les tenir
informés et même à les acculturer aux
questions liées aux liés au nucléaire
donc je voudrais nous voudrions avoir
quelques quelques précisions quelques
précisions là-dessus je pense que les
Français ont besoin sur ces questions là
de confiance et que la confiance se
gagne en apportant des informations
régulières et en faisant la preuve
effectivement de cette indépendance
scientifique notamment des personnels de
l'URSS je vous remercie merci
pour merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Directeur
Général pour ma part la question de la
fusion pose deux difficultés celles
d'ordre organisationnel aujourd'hui mais
aussi celle de l'absorption de la charge
de travail à venir compte tenu de la
relance annoncée de la filière nucléaire
il existe aujourd'hui un réel consensus
sur le fait que la charge de travail
donc à la fois sur le contrôle et
l'expertise va s'accroître dans les
prochaines années de manière
considérable côté parc nucléaire les
quatrième examens de sûreté sont en
cours il va falloir préparer le passage
au-delà de 50 ans et instruire la
possibilité d'exploiter ou de la de 60
ans en même temps la France donc va
relancer un programme de construction de
six nouveaux réacteurs PR2 soutenir
plusieurs startups dont l'objectif va
être de travailler sur les nouvelles
technologies de rupture donc je l'ai
bien entendu il s'agira donc pour le
Parlement
selon vous de nous exprimer dans le
cadre de la procédure législative de
vous laisser la possibilité de définir
les moyens donc je pense qu'il serait
intéressant et c'est l'objet de ma
question de nous en dire plus puisque
aujourd'hui la réflexion est en cours
sur les moyens que vous envisagez demain
de quel ordre en termes de moyens
financiers de moyens humains ce qu'on
envisage aujourd'hui
d'aller sur une organisation autre aussi
à ce niveau là je vous remercie
pour terminer Evelyne Renaud garabée
rapidement merci Madame présidente
monsieur le Président l'Office préconise
de monnaie une étude internationale
permettant de tirer tous les
enseignements possibles des systèmes
intégrés étrangers et en retenant les
meilleures parties que disponibles lors
de votre intervention vous nous avez
rapidement évoqué les modèles intégrés
d'autorité de sûreté dans le monde
occidental pouvez-vous me donner des
exemples étrangers de système intégré et
préciser leurs avantages merci
voilà monsieur le Président je me suis
le directeur nous vous écoutons merci
madame la Présidente merci mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs pour ces
questions je vais en prendre certaines
et je laisserai Olivier gutta répondre à
d'autres alors tout d'abord en ce qui
concerne la reprise des préconisations
de l'OPEX et le fait de les décliner
dans la loi en les précisant le cas
échéant moi je l'ai dit les six
recommandations de l'OPEX me paraissent
excellente et je n'ai aucune
appréhension et elles sont formulées me
semble-t-il en termes d'objectifs donc
les reprendre sous la forme appropriée
dans la loi ne me pose pas de
difficultés ce que je dis c'est
attention à ne pas aller au-delà et
ajouter les modalités selon lesquelles
ces objectifs seraient mis en oeuvre au
sein de la structure chez le sénateur
lui c'est ça ma préoccupation
et c'est d'ailleurs logique par rapport
à au statut d'indépendance aussi de la
SN et à mon avis acceptable à partir du
moment où il a été suggéré par l'OPEX
qu'il y ait un certain nombre de
rendez-vous qui vous paraissent tout à
fait logique tout au long de la mise en
place de la réforme pour qu'il y ait un
échange sur la manière dont la SN la
nouvelle ASN répondra aux objectifs
fixés par l'OPEX donc pour moi voilà
c'est ce n'est aucun aucune difficulté
avec ça mais je dis attention n'en
allons pas loin je ne souhaiterais pas
que l'on que l'on définisse des
obligations de moyens qui ensuite nous
nous contraires alors qu'on a même pas
encore commencé à réfléchir sur la
manière dont on va s'organiser
l'organisation ça sera pas une ASM
actuelle étendue ça sera pas une IRSN
étendue ce sera quelque chose de nouveau
qui va falloir inventer dans le respect
des principes qui sont définis donc
laissons-nous des marges de manœuvre
avec bien sûr l'obligation de rapporter
d'expliquer de présenter les
propositions qui sont faites c'est ça
c'est ça mon point ne créons pas une
IRSN à l'intérieur de la SN avec les
mêmes barrières et les mêmes
organisations ça aurait pas de sens à ce
moment-là
sénateur salmon alors la méthode de la
réforme bien évidemment il ne
m'appartient pas en tant que président
d'une autorité indépendante du
gouvernement de commenter la méthode
retenue par le gouvernement
je ne ferai aucun commentaire là-dessus
en revanche je crois avoir dans mon
interventionaire expliqué si cette
réforme est effectivement arrive à son
terme les conséquences positives
qu'elles pourraient avoir sur le
dispositif de contrôle et bien
évidemment dans toujours dans un sens à
la fois d'efficacité mais aussi de
renforcement de la confiance il y
aura-t-il des changements technologiques
qui justifieraient que une approche
différente soit mise en place mais bien
sûr on a parlé des SMS on parle aussi
des réacteurs de quatrième génération on
parle peut-être même de la fusion donc
il va y avoir des évolutions
technologiques évidentes alors on est à
l'échelle du nucléaire c'est pas demain
matin ça va prendre du temps raison de
plus d'ailleurs pour faire la réforme et
la d'une certaine manière la mettre en
oeuvre avant que les nouvelles
technologies soient effectivement des
sujets qui qui se posent à nous et qu'il
faut et qu'il faudra prendre en charge
avec des compétences nouvelles et qui
sont à mettre en place
bon les relations nous l'avons dit sont
bonnes entre la SN et l'IRSN
je ne pense pas que ça soit un argument
pour dire on ne fait pas de réforme
c'est pas parce que les gens s'entendent
bien que on doit laisser les choses en
l'état c'est plus difficile quand ils
sont en train de mal de faire une
réforme mais bon il me semble que il y a
quand même des éléments qui font prendre
en compte
les nouveaux risques émergents notamment
vous avez parlé ces intervenant ville de
la les nouveaux risques émergents
notamment cybersécurité
réchauffement climatique c'est
effectivement des sujets d'anticipation
à très long terme et sur la
cybersécurité j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
c'est un sujet qui est rattaché à la
sécurité des installations civiles et je
pense qu'il faut que sécurité et sûreté
de l'installation civile en termes
d'expertise soit maintenu au sein de la
même entité ce n'est pas le texte
actuellement et d'autre part en ce qui
concerne le réchauffement climatique
monsieur moi-même exprimé en début
d'année en disant que dans la
perspective d'une relance nucléaire avec
des poursuites d'exploitation du parc
actuel au-delà de 50 de 60 ans et la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs on va
avoir effectivement une pression je
dirais sur l'ensemble du milieu naturel
qui va être beaucoup plus importante et
donc il faut l'anticiper et la manière
de l'anticiper c'est y compris en
faisant des évolutions technologiques
aujourd'hui on a des systèmes de
refroidissement sur les centrales
nucléaires qui consomment beaucoup d'eau
et qui nécessite des traitements
sanitaires notamment parce qu'il y a des
traitements biocides sur les réacteurs
qui sont équipés d'aéros réfléchir en
tout ça ça nécessite dans une
perspective de changement climatique de
se poser la question des de la gestion
des ressources en eau qui est partagée
pas uniquement pour l'énergie mais avec
d'autres acteurs sur la manière ou de où
on va installer les installations
nucléaires nouvelle quelle technologie
vont-elles être développée ça à prendre
du temps ça pas peut-être 20 ans ou 30
ans mais il faut se poser la question et
je pense qu'avoir une expertise intégrée
et une recherche intégrée sur la sûreté
et sur les sujets d'impact
environnementaux ne permettra à la SN
nouvelle
décision est prise d'avoir une véritable
dialogue technique et un pouvoir
d'influence vis-à-vis des exploitants
madame kaker je laisserai Olivier cupard
répondra au sénateurs
alors vous m'interrogez et je comprends
cette question mais c'est très difficile
nous sommes au tout début d'abord
l'iPhone n'est pas voté on a pas
commencé les groupes de travail vous
savez que la ministre nous avait mandaté
pour que nous fassions des propositions
de méthodes pour pouvoir mettre en place
la réforme si elle était décidée c'est
ce que nous avons fait d'ailleurs nous
avons fait conjointement avec le
directeur général de l'IRSN avec
l'administrateur général du CEA nous
avons fait une propulsion de méthodes et
parmi ces éléments de méthode il y a
effectivement tous les sujets liés à aux
besoins aux compétences en renforcement
des ressources humaines et ressources
financières et la ministre nous a dit
que ce point si bien sûr rend la réforme
est évoquée devait être précisé pour
pouvoir être progrès dans la discussion
sur la loi de finance 2024 donc c'est ça
notre calendrier c'est dès que les
signaux s'ils le sont positifs pour
pouvoir engager la réforme que nous
puissions réfléchir sur les besoins à la
fois en compétences en ressources
humaines et en finance pour pouvoir
assurer l'accompagnement du programme
électronucléaire ambitieux donc ça sera
avec vous un autre rendez-vous qui sera
le rendez-vous de la discussion sur la
loi de finance 2024 et je terminerai par
la sénatrice Renault garabédian sur les
exemples étrangers je pense que c'est
absolument fondamental effectivement que
dans la réflexion si la l'orientation
qui a été donnée par le gouvernement et
maintenu que nous nous inspirions des
meilleures pratiques en matière de
fonctionnement et d'organisation de deux
homologues étrangers qui ont à la fois
l'expertise la recherche et la décision
en leur sein mais avec ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est il s'agit pas
d'avoir deux organisations qui sont
juxtaposées et qui se parlent pas
d'ailleurs c'est ça serait idiot parce
que ce n'est pas le cas où tu es bien
définir quelque chose de nouveau qui
soit le plus efficace possible et qui
s'inspire des meilleures pratiques il y
aura à l'évidence dans les
comptes-rendus qui nous sont demandés
des retours qui nous sont demandés vers
le Parlement besoin d'aller plus avant
dans la question que vous posez pour
expliquer au parlementaire la mission
dans d'étude qui aurait été faite pour
dire voilà ce que nous proposons voilà
comment ça se positionne par rapport au
meilleures pratiques à l'étranger mais
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas fait ce
travail je laisse Olivier pour répondre
à sur la question de d'indépendance
d'esprit monsieur le sénateur je rejoins
tout à fait mais c'est c'est bien ce à
quoi on s'attache d'ores et déjà au sein
même de la SN finalement notre travail
de tous les j'allais dire
personnellement mon travail de tous les
jours en tant que directeur général
c'est de préparer les décisions pour le
collège et de faire en sorte justement
que dans la préparation de ces décisions
chacun chacune puisse exprimer son point
de vue technique
librement en toute indépendance encore
une fois et en conscience
sur les questions sur tes nucléaires et
de la rédoration il y a d'ailleurs enfin
on par rapport à cette question de de
dispositif à snyrasn il y a aussi
beaucoup de décisions qui sont prises
par l'ASN sans saisir de l'IRSN en bas
en particulier dans le domaine du
nucléaire médical
toutes les décisions d'autorisation des
services de médecine nucléaire de
radiothérapie ou en tout cas je vais
dire pas forcément absolument toutes
mais
une très très large majorité d'entre
elles sont prises sans consultation de
l'IRSN et donc il y a bien une analyse
technique qui est faite dans me
semble-t-il dans des bonnes conditions
je n'ai jamais entendu quiconque
contester
la manière dont nous travaillons
aujourd'hui sur ces questions là et et
encore une fois le
l'organisation aujourd'hui de la SN je
peux en témoigner elle permet à un
chargé d'affaires j'allais dire qui
travaille à vraiment à la base de la
pyramide
dans les réunions du Collège des
Commissaires de dire au président qu'il
n'est pas d'accord avec lui sur tel
point de lui dire bah voilà sur tel
point moi je pense que et c'est ce à
quoi nous nous attachons de façon plus
générale on parle souvent de culture de
sûreté chez les industriels qui est un
point absolument fondamental de la
sûreté nucléaire et de la radio
rédaction il y a aussi naturellement de
la même manière
un sujet de culture de sûreté au sein de
l'autorité de contrôle il faut
naturellement que les conditions de
travail que nous offrons aux personnes
les conditions d'organisation de prise
de décision permettent à chacun de se
poser toutes les questions qu'il a
besoin de se poser de les remonter au
bon niveau voilà donc c'est c'est des
garanties aujourd'hui de travail que
nous offrons à nos à nos personnels et
que nous offrirons demain si la réforme
va à son terme dans un ensemble élargi
dans ma question je j'avais demandé
comment vous en faites la démonstration
de ce que vous venez de dire que je
partage que je souhaite par ailleurs et
pas de problème là-dessus moi je pense
qu'il faut en faire la démonstration à
l'externe et ça renvoie ce que vous
disiez de la relation avec les
populations etc qui est fondamental
voilà comment comment vous y procédez un
des éléments j'ai fait référence ce sont
ces fameuses audits par les pairs
étrangers c'est à dire des des
personnels en fait des dirigeants dans
pas mal de cas d'autorité de sûreté
étrangère qui viennent nous auditer nous
poser des questions sur justement la
manière dont nous travaillons au regard
d'un référentiel international c'est un
des c'est un des éléments je pense qu'il
y a aussi après si on va aux résultats
les décisions elles-mêmes de la SN qui
peuvent en témoigner
peut-être rajouter un point parce qu'on
a beaucoup parlé expertise décision on
n'a pas parlé contrôle et contrôle c'est
effectivement très important ce sont les
inspecteurs de la SN qui réalise les
contrôles ils sont parfois assistés de
certains chargés de sites de l'URSS mais
contenu organisation territoriale c'est
l'ASN qui porte le poids du contrôle
toutes les lettres de suite par rapport
à la visibilité à l'extérieur toutes les
lettres de suite d'inspection il y en a
plusieurs milliers sont systématiquement
mis en ligne pour être visible je peux
faire le parallèle avec la vie de
d'expertise de l'irset pour être visible
du grand public toutes les réunions que
nous avons dans les clips sont en
général des réunions dans lesquelles les
clients rebondissent sur les conclusions
des inspections que nous avons menées
pour interpeller l'exploitant en notre
présence en disant la SN a pointé du
doigt tel sujet dites nous comment ça
marche donc voyez-vous nous savons déjà
une grande ouverture par rapport en
termes de transparence et de relations
avec le public qui sont liées à nos
opérations de contrôle et ça c'est
fondamental de le conserver
bien merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Directeur Général pardon de
devoir couper cette audition un peu trop
rapidement donc nous avons bien compris
que si cette réforme était adoptée par
le Parlement nous rentrions nous
rentrerions pardon dans une période de
préfiguration de la nouvelle entité sur
lequel il serait quand même important
que le Parlement est quelques points de
contrôle de suivi et évidemment tant le
sujet de la sûreté est important
effectivement à nos yeux merci beaucoup
voilà je pense qu'une telle
préfiguration
ça s'invente pas le matin en se rasant
et donc je redis voilà non pas à votre
adresse mais à l'adresse du gouvernement
notre grand mécontentement voilà sur
l'ordonnancement de tout cela voilà
merci beaucoup en tout cas monsieur le
Président et Monsieur le Directeur
Général merci
mes chers collègues
après avoir échangé avec le président de
l'ASN nous auditionnons à présent
monsieur Jean-Christophe Niel directeur
général de l'Institut de radioprotection
et de sûreté nucléaire l'IRSN je
souhaiterais vous poser des questions
qui sont proches de celles que j'ai
soumise au président de l'ASN il y a
quelques instants monsieur le Président
que pensez-vous d'abord de la méthode
retenue par le gouvernement ça je sais
pas si vous êtes en capacité de vous
exprimer là-dessus mais en tout cas nous
c'est un gros sujet pour nous qui
consiste à présenter deux amendements à
un projet de loi que nous avons déjà
examiné sans ces amendements ici au
Sénat la concertation et l'évaluation
vous semblait ce jour assez assez vous
semble-t-elle pardon suffisante sinon
quel serait la méthode adaptée pour
procéder à une telle réforme plus encore
quel est votre point de vue
naturellement sur le contenu de cette
réforme le contexte de relance nucléaire
est-il propice à une telle réforme
quelle est son incidence sur sûreté
nucléaire dans la mesure où l'IRSN émet
un avis sur les décisions de l'ASN y
a-t-il un risque de confusion entre
expertise et contrôle voire pire une
perte d'expertise et dans les
recommandations de l'OPEX celle-ci a
préconisé de maintenir celui-ci pardon à
préconisé de maintenir une séparation
entre contrôler expertise ainsi que les
compétences en bloc de l'IRSN tant
d'expertise que de recherche la réforme
présentée par le gouvernement vous
paraît donc être vous paraît-elle
excusez-moi être satisfaisante sur ces
deux points donc voilà je vous laisse
répondre peut-être à ces premières
questions un peu général et un peu
globale et puis ensuite je leur donnerai
la parole à Daniel grimillet qui est
notre rapporteur propose
bien sûr monsieur le
oui bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr donc
l'IRSN c'est l'expert public du risque
radiologique et nucléaire et les 1700
salariés de l'Institut que je salue je
tiens à saluer un large champ de
compétences croisées
compétences que l'IRSN mobilise pour
bien assurer ses missions
ses activités de recherche de
surveillance d'expertise
y compris en situation d'urgence il y a
SN trade de l'ensemble des usages des
rayonnements ionisants des procédés
industriels à leur application médicale
jusqu'aux effets de la radioactivité
naturelle sur la santé l'environnement
depuis 20 ans on dirait SN remplissait
missions les remplis de manière
rigoureuse complète et intègre son
organisation actuelle permet de
mobiliser les compétences de institut à
tout moment pour toutes ces missions il
y a SN fait appel aux compétences de ces
experts de ces chercheurs en continu car
la recherche et l'expertise sont
imbriquées et portées dans certains
domaines par les mêmes personnes la
force de l'IRSN c'est la complémentarité
de tous les champs couverts
la qualité de son travail est reconnue
d'ailleurs je comprends que cette
décision n'est pas une critique du
travail de l'URSS je voulais rappeler
aussi que l'appui technique de l'IRSN à
la SN représente 25% de notre activité
il reste allumé son expertise au service
de nombreux autorités et opérateurs
publics Direction générale de la santé
direction générale du travail ministère
des Affaires étrangères ministère de la
transition écologique aujourd'hui le
gouvernement a décidé de faire évoluer
l'organisation du contrôle de la sortie
nucléaire et mon intervention s'inscrit
dans cette logique et mon propos
liminaire s'articule autour de trois
points clés la séparation entre l'expert
le décideur
l'indispensable combinaison entre
expertise et recherche et les enjeux de
maintien des compétences pour répondre
au rendez-vous qui viennent
je pense utile de rappeler les
fondements de l'organisation actuelle de
la sûreté nucléaire en France l'accident
de Tchernobyl de 1986 a conduit à des
réflexions sur les facteurs
organisationnels des processus
décisionnels et sur l'importance des
arbitrages entre les préoccupations de
sûreté et les autres préoccupations les
réflexions issues des grandes crises
médiatiques politiques sanitaires des
années 90 sont contaminés vaches folles
ont progressivement amené à modifier le
système français de sûreté nucléaire et
de radioprotection et ses évolutions ont
abouti à la création en 2002 de l'IRSN
et en 2006 de l'ASN au cours des années
cette organisation a légitimement été
requestionnée plusieurs fois
son efficacité a été démontrée confirmé
le principe de séparation des fonctions
d'évaluation et de gestion du risque est
également au cœur du dispositif de
sécurité sanitaire possible par
incontournable dans le nouveau système à
venir de maintien une décision
distinction très claire entre expertise
et décision y compris dans une même
organisation c'est d'ailleurs ce qui se
passe à l'Autorité de sûreté américaine
qui est souvent cité en exemple
les règles sont très claires pour
séparer les commissaires des services
qui préparent les décisions de même le
principe de publication des avis
techniques support à la décision devrait
également être maintenu pour assurer la
transparence du système et la bonne
information du public infinie c'est ce
qui contribue à la confiance dans le
système de contrôle j'en viens mon
deuxième point l'indispensable
combinaison à la création de l'IRSN il a
été fait le choix de rassembler
expertise de recherche les compétences
techniques de l'URSS reposent sur
d'importants programmes de recherche
avec les industriels français et des
partenaires européens et internationaux
les recherches expérimentales permettent
de développer des codes de calcul
indispensables à l'expertise tout comme
en situation de crise c'est dans son
rapport provisoire d'évaluation de de
l'URSS que je viens de recevoir que le
Haut Conseil à l'évaluation
de la recherche et de l'enseignement
supérieur qualifie le modèle expertise
recherche de l'IRSN de performant et de
structurant dans les grands programmes
et réseaux européens ça date de Y a 10
jours les avis des ASN expriment un état
des connaissances à l'état de l'art
l'engagement de programme de recherche
anticipe des problématiques nouvelles
les activités d'expertise et de
recherche sont souvent menées par les
mêmes personnes notamment dans le
domaine de la protection contre les
rayonnements ionisants j'en termine avec
les enjeux de maintien des compétences
je vais y être extrêmement vigilant en
réponse aux enjeux climatiques
énergétiques de souveraineté la relance
du nucléaire a été engagée de nombreux
dossiers d'expertise sont en cours à
titre d'exemple la prolongation des
réacteurs en exploitation au-delà de 60
ans
l'examen de la demande d'autorisation de
création du site de stockage souterrain
Cigéo cela entraîne une charge
d'expertise très importante l'IRSN s'y
prépare depuis plusieurs années il a
organisé son travail en interaction avec
la SN pour rendre des avis dans des
délais compatibles avec les échanges de
prise de décision
les RSN a déjà montré sa capacité à être
réactif et en anticiper c'est le cas
pour les évaluations de sûreté mises en
oeuvre après l'accident de Fukushima
c'est aussi le cas plus récemment pour
la prolongation de l'exploitation
directeur de 900 MW au-delà de 40 ans
pour lequel il y a SN a rendu un avis de
synthèse en plein confinement en mars
2020 au-delà de la sûreté nucléaire dans
le domaine de la santé l'évolution des
technologies utilisant des rayonnements
ionisants pour le diagnostic et pour le
thérapeutique nécessite une vigilance
particulière pour s'assurer de la
balance bénéfices risques pour les
patients et Assieu leur assure un
traitement
c'est aussi cela notre rôle alors cette
nouvelle période elle suscite de fortes
inquiétudes chez les salariés de
l'Institut c'est évidemment pas sans
impact sur celui-ci et dans un marché de
l'emploi tendu je vais être privilégiant
pour préserver l'attractivité de nos
missions il s'agit d'éviter une perte de
compétences en sûreté nucléaire en
radioprotection à court et moyen terme
je souhaite rappeler pour conclure que
la cadence et la charge d'expertise et
de recherche pour les années à venir est
importante les équipes de l'IRSN plus je
remercie pour leur engagement ce sont
organisés pour répondre à ces enjeux et
être à la hauteur de leur mission de
service public pour conclure ma qualité
de dirigeants de ce bel établissement
public kellyn je travaille comme me le
demande ma lettre de mission à formuler
des propositions de mise en oeuvre de
cette décision des évolutions et des
améliorations des organisations sont
possibles dans le cadre de la politique
nucléaire souhaitée par le gouvernement
néanmoins il faut se donner le temps
nécessaire pour tirer le meilleur parti
des deux organisations des deux
associations qui font un travail de
qualité au service des pouvoirs publics
je vous remercie
convaincu un certain nombre de
partenaires étrangers notamment
d'ailleurs de l'utiliser donc voilà une
démarche qui commence par une analyse un
état des lieux alors risque de confusion
expertise contrôle ça c'est un point
fondamental
il est souvent fait référence à
l'Autorité de sûreté américaine
alors ce qu'il faut savoir excuse-moi je
vois un petit peu d'eau
il est souvent fait référence à
l'autorité de surta América Nord dans
tous les pays qui ont des réacteurs
nucléaires il y a une autorité de sûreté
c'est une exigence des conventions
internationales la sûreté nucléaire
c'est une matière scientifique et
technique non les facteurs humains les
espaces et c'est une matière
scientifique donc dans toutes les
autorités de sûreté s'appuient
sur des analyses des expertises
techniques et scientifiques c'est le
rôle d'évoluer à ce qu'on appelle les
technicalceptiques organisation les
organisations techniques de sûreté c'est
le Jarro international et au niveau
international les les modèles sont très
variables il y a une il y a une grande
variété de modèles sur la manière dont
l'autorité qui va prendre des décisions
faire les inspections l'argumentation et
connecter à cet organisme technique et
scientifique donc en France ces deux
entités séparées comme dans d'autres
pays à part en Corée
par exemple en Chine par exemple en
Belgique en Allemagne c'est pas
forcément mon exemple c'est l'histoire
du nucléaire voilà il y a d'autres
exemples plus intégrés dans tous les cas
ça cette expertise technique à la NRC
d'autorité de surta américaine elle est
largement intégrée néanmoins ils ont
aussi recours à une expertise technique
extérieure de l'ordre de
15%. alors ce qui me semble important
c'est que chaque pays définisse son
modèle de contrôle de la sûreté en
rapport avec ce qu'il est ça peut pas
être fait hors sol et je vous donne un
exemple aux États-Unis aujourd'hui il y
a 92 réacteurs 56 en France mais il y a
30 exploitants d'accord on voit bien
qu'il y a des exploitants qui ont deux
réacteurs donc bien évidemment
l'approche de sûreté pour une structure
qui a deux réacteurs ou clairement il y
a pas une grande ingénierie il y a pas
beaucoup de compétences tout simplement
c'est une petite taille n'est pas
forcément il faut pas forcément suivre
la même approche que dans un système
comme système français qui a la chance
parce que je pense que c'est une chance
d'un point de vue sûreté d'avoir des
grands opérateurs qui ont des capacités
d'ingénierie d'aller steak forte donc il
faut il le système de contrôle par
rapport à cette à cette situation
d'ailleurs l'auto était surté américaine
est beaucoup plus normatif que
l'autorité de sureté franquette pourquoi
parce qu'elle doit répondre à une
situation qui est la suivante c'est
quand ils prennent une décision
notamment contraignante pour un
opérateur cette opérateur va évidemment
vérifier si la même décision est
appliquée aux voisins vous voyez
situation qui aujourd'hui n'existe pas
en France alors certes il y a des SMS
qui vont arriver et aujourd'hui il y a
un seul opérateur et donc c'est très
structurant alors au-delà de ça une fois
qu'on a dit ça et je considère qu'il y a
plein de modèles qui peuvent fonctionner
dont le système français qui aujourd'hui
ne me semble pas poser de problème je
crois que ça a été confirmé par
président de la SN juste avant dans les
systèmes à à plus intégré comme la NRC
américaine ou le système coréen vous
avez un
China je suis passé le bon terme entre
l'autorité et et les services par
exemple j'ai pris un document qui montre
ce qu'elle a NRC la version toteuse
américaine on voit bien ça même un nom
qui s'appelle le ergat c'est entre les
services qui vont faire l'instruction
des dossiers et la décision il y a
quelque chose ça permet à regarder c'est
fait pour ça et aujourd'hui les les
commissaires de la NRC c'est ces cinq
commissaires plus déséquipes qui sont
une cinquantaine de personnes pour les
aider à préparer en Corée c'est pareil
l'Autorité de sûreté elle-même fait 160
personnes l'Autorité de sûreté coréenne
s'appuie sur deux organismes un
organisme s'occupe technique un TSO
c'est un oreille collègue de l'URSS qui
s'appelle keans et un autre organisme
qui va s'occuper de non prolifération
donc l'autorité de sûreté le coréenne là
aussi 160 personnes donc c'est encore
plus gros mais elle s'appuie sur deux
pieds un pied non prolifération sécurité
et un pied sur T le pied sur T fait 600
personnes vous voyez il y a plein de
modèles différents en tout état de cause
dans tous les modèles et une séparation
expertise des Sion et ça pour moi il est
vraiment fondamental de le de le
conserver y compris dans une évolution
du système si celle-ci devait être
devait être mise en œuvre
recommandations de lopesque alors bien
évidemment les alors Lopez qui est à
l'origine de la création des des du
système de contrôle actuel il est
important de le rappeler je crois que
les présidents de l'Office l'ont rappelé
dans leur prise de parole
récentes dans une tribune c'est que
c'est des processus longs le rapport
fondateur du système de contrôle de la
sûreté nucléaire de protection française
est un rapport de de Jean-Yves le déo
qui date de 1998 qui était lui-même le
fruit de nombreuses années de réflexion
98 mise en oeuvre à l'IRSN en 2002 la SN
en 2006 donc le nucléaire comme ça a été
rappelé par Bernard de rue c'est c'est
une discipline du temps long y compris
dans l'évolution des des organisations
on dirait SN et en relation fréquentes
avec cette organisation notamment on
présente notre rapport d'activité tous
les ans on a été auditionné peut-être
que vous souhaiteriez revenir sur les
les phénomènes de corrosion sous
contrainte il y a pas très longtemps et
surtout sujet sur tout l'important on
avait été auditionné de l'EPA alors il y
a un certain nombre de recommandations
de de de
l'Office Parlementaire notamment trois
grands principes maintient des
compétences séparation expertise des
sillons transparence évidemment l'IRSN
ne peut qu'adhérer ça fait partie de
notre ADN à ces trois grands principes
donc on est évidemment d'accord avec ça
dans ce premier boulet de point si je
peux m'exprimer un site il y avait aussi
le besoin d'une analyse des forces et
faiblesses du système actuel et je tiens
apprécié tout de suite que l'IRSN ayant
tout à fait ouvert
à faire un état des lieux du
fonctionnement actuel de ses forces de
ses faiblesses pour pour l'améliorer
des réunions des commissaires sont
publiques c'est-à-dire toutes les
réunions sont publiques à l'exception de
ce qui touche à la sécurité de ce qui
touche à des sujets internes de
management l'autorité sur terre
américaine aussi un rôle de juge donc ça
c'est c'est fermé mais sinon c'est
public j'ai eu l'occasion de partir des
rayons publics donc aujourd'hui c'est
l'action qu'il faut se poser c'est il
faut pas non plus acheter les modèles
par appartement il faut les voir
globalement au Japon c'est public
d'accord aux États-Unis il faut savoir
que c'est très très exigeant je pense
que ce serait quelque chose à regarder
de près parce que je suis pas sûr que
c'est désavantage mais toute réunion
entre les services de la NRC et les
opérateurs fait l'objet d'un compte
rendu public donc il faut vraiment
prendre le sujet dans sa globalité pas
juste dire c'est intégré donc voilà il
faut regarder la globalité du du système
donc voilà donc système intégré voilà ne
pas dégrader le fonctionnement dans la
dans la période transitoire donc ça
c'est vrai que c'est c'est une
inquiétude ce matin j'ai été informé que
on a une équipe qui s'appelle le bureau
de le Berry je sais plus quels sont les
qui s'occupe d'inondation donc ils sont
en première ligne sur le changement
climatique ils ont été tous contactés
par un laboratoire d'EDF quand même
c'est la façon que j'ai de ce matin donc
le risque c'est aussi celui-là
déstabilisations des équipes il y a une
position de Lopez sur le monopole donc à
force de monopole
en ce moment pour les super salariés de
l'IRSN c'est une période de stabilisante
d'accord au moment où les opérateurs
vont chercher à recruter un certain
nombre de gens d'accord ce matin j'ai
appris parce que j'ai demandé qu'on me
fasse remonter les cas j'ai appris que
les que cette équipe là ils avaient été
contactés par laboratoire d'EDF en
disant voilà si vous voulez venir chez
nous vous pouvez d'accord oui c'est ça
que je veux dire voilà c'est ça le
risque le risque c'est ça c'est que
période instable nos gens sont
compétents ils sont très bien connus par
les opérateurs donc voilà donc c'est ça
c'est ça un des risques sur le monopole
expertise alors nous on revendique pas
du tout le monopole de l'expertise au
contraire je pense que c'est aussi pour
ça que c'est bien d'avoir une autorité
et un expert technique je pense que les
sujets de gestion ce risque il se
bonifie dans la confrontation des
argumentations donc sur le sur le risque
clair le fait qu'il n'autorité et un
expert technique qui regarde le même
sujet chacun de leurs points de vue et
bon pour la sûreté le fait qu'il y ait
des experts autres soit dans le domaine
académique soit non institutionnel c'est
aussi bon je signale un des
caractéristiques du système français qui
là aussi conduit à bien regarder le
contexte national c'est que le système
français il est très centré sur des gros
opérateurs aujourd'hui en France
l'essentiel de la recherche nucléaire
est faite aussi il y en impôt au CNRS
quand vous allez dans d'autres pays
comme les États-Unis c'est beaucoup plus
réparti aux États-Unis vous pouvez
trouver des universitaires et dans
d'autres pays d'ailleurs qui travaillent
sur la société donc c'est aussi un
élément à prendre en compte enfin nous
on est favorable à la diversité de de
l'expertise y compris chez l'expérience
il y a un sujet de financement qui
faudrait peut-être se poser un jour
c'est à dire je pense que c'est aussi
simple pour le système qui est ces
experts
beaucoup d'usage à des codes de
simulation trois dimensions ce qui était
pas le cas il y a 10 ans donc là il a
fallu qu'on s'adapte qu'on développe de
nouvelles méthodes qu'on fasse des
nouveaux calculs donc voilà donc je suis
moi complètement en phase avec la
recommandations de lopesque avec un
point d'attention sur le système
intérieur où je pense que si ce travail
est fait il faut l'élargir bien au-delà
des des systèmes intégrés
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Daniel Grémillet oui merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
je souhaiterais vous interroger sur des
sujets similaires à ceux évoquer avec le
président de la SN d'abord le rapport du
15 avril 2014 de la SN de l'IRSN dans
lequel vous appeliez tous deux à
maintenir un dispositif dual vous
semble-t-il toujours d'actualité le
contexte a-t-il changé en disant au
point d'envisager une réforme en sens
contraire plus encore que pensez-vous de
la réforme proposée par le gouvernement
le premier abonnement présenté par lui
sur la consolidation des attributions de
la SN reprend-il bien l'ensemble des
missions de l'IRSN
sont ceux qu'on amendement sur les
transferts des personnels du RSN
garantit-il le maintien des personnels
des compétences et des rémunérations
votre intervention tout de suite apporte
déjà une partie des réponses des risques
à quelles conditions cette réforme
serait-elle acceptable à l'inverse créée
du système de contrôle évoqué dans la
délibération du 16 février de votre
conseil administration quel que soit des
modalités de cette réforme enfin que
pensez-vous des recommandations de
l'OPEX là aussi vous avez commencé de
répondre partiellement qui a appelé à
l'absence de monopole dans l'expertise
nucléaire et à la prise en compte du
retour d'expérience des systèmes
intégrés étrangers la réforme envisagée
par le gouvernement répondait l'acide
demande merci Monsieur le Directeur
Général
alors de mon point de vue le système
asnrsn fonctionnent bien l'IRSN
fonctionne bien et c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est le président de la SN qui l'a
répété à plusieurs reprises et qu'il l'a
écrit dans le cadre des auditions je
crois qu'il l'a dit tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs
j'étais derrière la porte
c'est pas bien élevé mais et donc il
l'écrit il va là on a voilà la Cour des
comptes qui a contrôlé l'IRSN pendant le
confinement d'ailleurs
a conclu que l'IRSN remplissait ses
missions avait atteint les objectifs de
son contrat l'objectif le rapport hcars
que j'ai cité tout à l'heure va aussi
dans le même sens donc moi je considère
que le système il y a certaines
fonctionnent bien et et le système asnia
et ça fonctionne bien c'est ce que
j'avais dit lors de mon audition pour ma
renomination suite à une question qui
m'avait été posée je considère que le
système n'a pas de n'a pas n'a pas
évolué ce point de vue là soyons très
très clair si je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
dire ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut
faire de l'auto satisfaction et dans le
voilà moi l'IRSN d'ailleurs les
personnels de yazen sont habitués à
évoluer et on a évidemment aucun aucun
aucune difficulté à à avancer alors les
avis sur les avis sur les amendements on
a encore c'est un petit peu difficile
pour moi ça a été je constate qu'il y a
quand même une évolution par rapport au
projet de départ puisque le projet de
départ la recherche de l'eau CEVA après
de manière très concrète là aussi ça a
été dit par Bernard drosus le travail
détaillé va se faire un groupe de
travail donc les intentions me semblent
y être après il va falloir aller voir
dans le détail les sujets sont complexes
je prends la recherche d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui il y a dans le recensement
qu'on a pu faire il y a aucune haït il y
a une activité de recherche en France
d'ailleurs au niveau international les
autorités de sûreté qui font de la
recherche ça se limite à travailler sur
des codes c'est important mais à ma
connaissance je crois encore le sous
contrôle de Karine j'ai je ne connais
pas d'auto-été de sûreté qui est des
laboratoires nous on a des laboratoires
avec des installations d'expérimentation
avec des très cher avec des voltmets
avec voilà donc on a des choses comme ça
à ma connaissance il y a pas d'autorité
de sûreté là quand on fait système
intégré il y a pas d'autorité de sûreté
qui est disponible de ce type là encore
à chaque pays doit inventer son système
donc c'est peut-être une invention à
avoir en France en tout cas aujourd'hui
c'est un sujet il y a pas d'aïe non plus
voilà donc je veux dire il y a il y a
des sur la recherche il y a il y a ces
sujets là il y a la capacité à avoir des
doctorants donc il semble que ce serait
possible dans une haie mais bien ça sent
ça va être confirmé les doctorants c'est
le point essentiel d'un risque de
recherche c'est la matière vive de la
recherche si vous n'avez pas de
doctorants vous ferez de la recherche
quelque temps parce que vous avez des
chercheurs mais très rapidement afin
d'attrition donc ça c'est une question
très concrète
alors la réponse qui se semble positive
et tout ça reste reste reste à confirmer
on a des on a des contrats avec un
certain nombre de partenaires notamment
industriels et étranger d'ailleurs j'ai
des partenaires qui m'ont contacté pour
nous interroger sur la poursuite de des
partenariats et puis et puis il y a les
codes aussi on développe des codes on en
vend un certain nombre on vend des
licences de code donc c'est des
questions là où le sujet doit être doit
être complètement approfondie sur les
personnes simplement la même chose mais
je crois que vous êtes bien conscient de
ça on a des personnes de droit privé qui
rejoindraient une autorité
administrative indépendante qui
aujourd'hui a des fonctionnaires des
contrats de droit public il y a
peut-être des adaptations mais ça aussi
c'est un sujet juridique et là
clairement d'ailleurs je suis pas je
suis pas compétent sur ces sujets mais
ces chefs évidemment regardez très près
si on veut effectivement que les
personnels comme ça comme ça étaient
annoncés soit transféré avec l'ensemble
de de de de de de de conditions de leur
contrat de travail leurs conditions de
travail
très bien je vais donner la parole à
d'autres sénateurs en bloc si vous me le
permettez Daniel salmon ensuite Franck
Montauger
merci madame la Présidente
le directeur pour votre exposé nous
sommes face à un espèce de
une espèce d'OPA hostile si on fait un
parallèle avec avec le privé
pouvez-vous nous donner quelques
éléments de dysfonctionnement qui
amènerait à
à ce changement de paradigme puisque
depuis des années les différents
rapports sont plutôt très
positif sur cette séparation de nos de
ces deux organismes des GEC la Cour des
comptes même l'enclide dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure est très très
excuse de cette de cette validité enfin
on peut même parler de système ternaire
puisqu'il y a non seulement il y a la
recherche expertise mais aussi le
contrôle la décision mais l'exploitant
et on voit que voilà les rapports avec
l'exploitants sont pas toujours évidents
vous avez parlé aussi de rendre publique
vous allez en faisant des parallèles
avec ce qui se passait aux USA
le système nucléaire français a souvent
brillé par son opacité je crois que
l'IRSN est un
pôle d'appui pour rendre public des
rapports
j'aimerais bien que vous nous donniez
quelques quelques éléments là-dessus
parce que je crois que ça vous a été
parfois parfois reproché est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner aussi votre vos rôles
particuliers dans certains nombre de de
difficultés de la filière nucléaire ou
au moins de
oui de difficultés là comme la corrosion
sous contrainte la falsification
concernant les cuves qui ont été faites
au Creusot aux Forges qu'elles aient
quelle a été votre rôle et également
votre rôle dans l'accident de Fukushima
vraiment pour voir et nous dire si dans
le cadre d'une fusion avec la SN vous
pourriez avoir cette même fonctionnement
qui ont donné plutôt satisfaction on va
dire merci
Monsieur le Directeur Général
merci d'avoir également insisté parce
que j'ai posé la question à Monsieur de
rosuk sur la question de la publicité
des travaux scientifiques et des
décisions qui sont prises
donc ma question par rapport à ce point
c'est voilà faut-il retenir de votre
propos qu'on peut en France et qu'on
doit faire beaucoup mieux sur ce sujet
parce que je pense effectivement qu'il y
a un enjeu considérable notamment dans
le par rapport à la question de la
confiance dans le nucléaire et dans le
rapport donc à la population aux
populations concernées et toute la
population française est concernée en
l'occurrence deuxième deuxième petite
question vous avez parlé
de déstabilisation
des personnels par rapport à l'annonce
de ce projet que vous avez d'ailleurs
parlé comme une décision qui était prise
donc voilà nous on est là pour faire
voiture balai quoi tant que
parlementaire entre parenthèses
comment ma question la suivante sur sur
ce point comment éviter la fuite de
compétences
le départ de compétences
vers d'autres cieux voir les trajets
et quel est donc à cet égard le projet
social et plus largement la manière dont
ce dont ce projet dans sa dimension
humaine
finalement est appréhendé quoi et
dérouler
merci
de parole je me permets de rajouter
quelques questions
ah pardon
une question c'était de savoir
comment vous vous envisagez
effectivement dans le cadre cette
accélération des installations
nucléaires
l'articulation entre justement cette
dans cette fusion de l'indépendance de
l'IRSN et savoir si justement cette
indépendance si cette fusion pardon
risque permettrait de fluidifier
davantage je dirais cette accélération
c'est ce qui nous a été présenté tout à
l'heure par par la
plus fatigué
voilà donc est-ce que vous pensez qu'à
la fois l'accélération est permise par
la fusion et comment elle peut garantir
néanmoins l'indépendance voilà un peu
plus clair
merci Laurent monsieur directeur général
peut-être quelques préoccupations
supplémentaires donc moi je m'associe
sur la question de la transition aux
inquiétudes des uns et des autres parce
que vous nous l'avez dit un certain
nombre de personnes sont déjà des
marchés
je vois qu'il y a des mouvements sociaux
qui s'inquiètent les syndicats
s'inquiètent au sein de l'URSS est-ce
que comment vous allez si cette décision
est confirmée par le Parlement comment
est-ce que vous allez pendant cette
période de transition qui sera forcément
longue
[Musique]
accompagnent vous faire accompagner par
les salariés de l'IRSN voilà quelle sera
la place au dialogue social qui sera la
place à la concertation avec avec votre
vos personnels qui sont évidemment
inquiets
ultra compétents et très appétant pour
d'autres instituts ou d'autres
entreprises ou d'autres États d'ailleurs
une question peut-être aussi également
peut-être ai-je mal compris mais vous
nous avez dit 25% de notre activité
c'est de travailler avec la SN le reste
c'est donc autre chose
comment cette autre chose va être gardé
par la s.n comment est-ce qu'il va être
sanctuarisé comment est-ce que tout cela
va s'organiser en tout cas quels sont
les priorités que vous donnerez dans le
terme de la configuration et dernière
chose aujourd'hui dans les contrôles et
dans les inspections que vous donnez
notamment à EDF que vous demandez à EDF
il y a des contrôles qui sont demandés
par vous il y a des contrôles qui sont
demandés par l'ASM comment est-ce qu'on
priorise tout ça peut-être ai-je mal
compris mais je voudrais savoir du point
de vue d'un exploitant qui a à faire à
la fois l'ASN et à vous-même comment en
fonction des différentes demandes il
s'organise et comment vous gérez les
priorités qui peuvent être des priorités
qui changent on voit bien le souci de
Pandi aujourd'hui voilà peut-être ça a
bougé et ça
consacrer un certain nombre de
ressources chez l'exploitant sur de
nouveaux sujets merci merci
fonctionnement donc moi j'ai
identifie pas de dysfonctionnement fort
mais comme je l'ai dit tant on peut
toujours s'améliorer là les temps
d'instruction dans lequel je mets
l'expertise de l'IRSN décision de la s.n
peut-être qu'on peut gagner en effacer
bien qu'aujourd'hui on est quand même
beaucoup travaillé on a mis depuis
quelques années des processus
d'amélioration par exemple de depuis
quelques temps sur les gros sujets on
fonctionne en groupe projet en 7ème
projet qu'un chef de projet de chaque
côté à la SN à l'IRSN et on a un
processus de de de suivi stratégique et
opérationnel et de différence c'est
quelque chose qui est pas très ancien ça
prend quelques années 5 ans voilà donc
on essaie de de d'être plus efficace et
on est tout à fait partisan et je pense
qu'on le fait d'ailleurs pour avancer
sur ce on le fait aussi en ayant un et
ça c'est un point important on définit
sur les gros ce qu'on appelle les
stratégies d'expertise faut être
conscient que quand on reçoit un dossier
de sûreté exploitant on regarde pas tout
le dossier de pair avant qu'on pose à
moins de questions c'était 40000 pages
avant qu'on pose à moins de questions
donc évidemment dans le métier de
l'expertise il y a avoir un avis sur le
risque incendie sur la thermodydraulique
mais il y a aussi avoir un avis et ça
c'est les experts qui ça se fait pas en
trois ans ça c'est c'est la fabrique de
l'expertise ça prend beaucoup de temps
au moins une dizaine d'années les les
experts très très experts confirmés on
va avoir une une capacité à identifier
les sujets en jeu et dire c'est cela sur
lequel il faut travailler et ça c'est
essentiel et ça ça fait partie de
l'objectif de priorisation
d'hiérarchisation on regarde pas tout
donc on peut travailler à géométrie
variable et dire sur ce sujet là on va
regarder ça parce que c'est essentiel ça
on va aller un peu plus vite puis ça on
va pas le regarder parce que honnêtement
c'est un peu accessoire donc ça fait
partie de de notre travail on peut on
peut certainement avancer d'ailleurs on
a des projets utilisant l'intelligence
artificielle
la cohérence moi de dysfonctionnement
majeur par contre on peut toujours
s'améliorer et on essaie de le faire on
est certifié ISO 9000 ans on a nos avis
c'est un process quoi c'est-à-dire on a
plusieurs centaines d'avis par an donc
on a une petite usine à produire des
avis non seulement la plusieurs avis par
an mais il faut savoir qu'en permanence
on a des choses programmées mais on
perdant c'est des aléas quand le quand
la fissure Pandi arrive c'est-à-dire à
suivre prioritaire donc évidemment on
n'a pas des gens sous le coude pour les
mettre dessus c'est à dire qu'on va
répartir le travail différemment et ça
c'est un travail permanent on a une
petite usine à faire des des
alors après publication des avis d'irisn
alors j'ai lu à droite à gauche dans la
presse des des choses sur l'application
des avis des recettes et je voulais
d'abord rappeler l'effet les avis des
Hassan sont publiés parce que c'est la
loi qui le demande c'est la loi
transition énergique pour une croissance
verte c'est la loi qui le demande elle
dit les avis d'irisens sont publiques
donc moi je respecte la loi donc les
avis de la Seine sont publiques
après il y a les modalités de
publication ça la loi n'en dit rien donc
ça ça fait partie d'une discussion avec
la SN et on a une convention cadre qui
court à un certain nombre de sujets de
l'appui technique de l'IRSN à l'ASN et
dans le cadre de cette convention cadre
on a une démarche qui explicité qui dit
à chaussures que signé par Bernard de
Rosu qui et moi en décembre 2021
donc cette convention canal dit quoi
elle dit que nos avis sont publiés dans
les 15 jours donc c'est au fil de l'eau
avec avec néanmoins de disposition qui
peut dire sur tel ou tel avis pour tel
ou telle raison on va pas le publier
tout de suite donc comme on a beaucoup
d'avis l'idée si on les publie au fil de
l'eau parce que même plus simple si on
les laisse
sédimenter ça risque d'être compliqué
donc on les met évidemment il y a des
sujets pour quelques raisons que ce soit
peuvent nécessiter de patienter un peu
et c'est ce qu'on fait et en accord avec
la SN tout ça c'est un processus
copiloté voilà alors rôle dans les
différents dans les différents sujets
sujets nucléaires donc quand ils ont
sous contrainte falsification du Creusot
accentugeva je propose ce carême que tu
que tu expliques
rapidement l'IRSN est donc chargée de
l'évaluation des risques pour la sûreté
donc pour tout ce qui concerne les
équipements house sous pression
typiquement comme les ségrégations
carbone ce qui a été vu au Creusot où
les problèmes de falsification l'IRSN va
regarder les conséquences pour la sûreté
et la nécessité ou non de faire des
actions avant de poursuivre le
fonctionnement des réacteurs l'aspect
falsification fraude est intégralement
géré par l'Autorité de sûreté mais
l'IRSN va regarder donc dès qu'il y a un
écart à la réglementation c'est la
direction des équipements sous pression
nucléaire qui est porteuse de la
réglementation dès qu'il y a un écart à
la réglementation c'est l'IRSN qui qui
utilise ses codes de calcul qui mènent
un certain nombre de recherches en
anticipation et qui va donner un avis
technique
sur un éclairage finalement technique
qui va permettre la prise de décision de
la SN sur le maintien en service ou pas
sur la corrosion sous contrainte le même
principe l'IRSN fait des calculs en
fonction de la taille de fissures de
l'endroit où ont lieu ces fissures pour
voir si l'intégrité des tuyauteries est
garantie ou non c'est également l'IRSN
qui fait des expertises sur les procédés
de contrôle des f a développé des
nouveaux procédés de contrôle pour
essayer d'évaluer par la mesure et non
pas par la destruction la profondeur des
défauts l'IRSN a été amené à rendre des
avis sur ces sujets et bien sûr nous
calculons les conséquences d'un accident
si s'il se produisait en lien avec ses
défauts sur la corrosion sous contrainte
par exemple nous avons rendu un avis
l'année dernière sur les conséquences
d'une double brèche sur le circuit
primaire qui pourrait être relié à ce
phénomène et de façon à vérifier comme
EDF l'avait prédit qu'il n'y aura pas de
risque de fusion du cœur dès lors qu'il
y avait double brèche une brèche étant
déjà couvert par
la démonstration de sûreté donc voilà
l'intervention de de l'IRSN alors quand
il s'agit des sujets équipés en sous
pression nucléaire effectivement c'est
en interface direct avec la direction
des équipements sous pression nucléaires
de la SN interface que nous avons
notablement amélioré depuis depuis des
années pour mieux s'articuler et avoir
un discours effectivement cohérent
vis-à-vis de l'exploitant
merci Karine donc si j'en viens aux
questions de sénateur mougeret
montoger pardon ça monte
donc sur les publications sur
l'application des travaux scientifiques
donc il y a deux sujets il y a les avis
il y a les avis que j'ai évoqué et puis
il y a on est en arts de recherche donc
on a aussi des publications
scientifiques donc là on obéit au canon
de la publication des des articles
scientifiques dans des revues dans des
revues de haut niveau à comité de
lecture alors sur les avis donc on les
publie mais en fait on va au-delà de ça
on a une démarche on a une démarche
depuis la création de l'IRSN il y a 20
ans d'ouverture à la société où l'idée
c'est d'interagir avec des acteurs de la
société civile notamment les experts
nutritionnels on le fait notamment au
travers des clés de l'ampli on a
beaucoup de relations avec les clients
et l'ampli les clés nous sollicitent
beaucoup un peu plus au moins une
centaine de fois par an sur des sujets
techniques on a aussi des démarches de
dialogues techniques d'ailleurs en lien
avec la SN
on va présenter échanger sur nos sujets
techniques alors pour nous cet échange
avec la société il est double sens
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas juste on
arrive avec notre savoir puis on
explique ce qu'on fait on interagit et
ça peut nous faire attirer notre
attention sur telle ou tel sujet et donc
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment interactif
et par ailleurs on veut aussi innover
donc on a créé il y a pas très longtemps
en accord avec nos tutelles un comité de
des parties prenantes dont l'objectif
est de réfléchir à de nouvelles manières
d'interagir avec les parties prenantes
il y a évidemment le schéma trail il y a
la publication c'est le niveau on va
dire 1 le niveau 2 c'est l'interaction
dans les réunions puis on essaie
d'imaginer d'autres systèmes on a par
exemple des démarches de de sciences
participative on a développé de l'amener
à système de mesure la radioactivité
accessible au public que le public
acquérir voilà donc on essaie de on
essaie d'élargir le champ de nos
Modalités de de de l'interaction un peu
plus qui évidemment dans une éventuelle
nouvelle organisation
ce serait un quelque chose qu'il
faudrait qu'il faudrait conserver alors
déstabilisation du personnel bon bah ça
c'est vraiment un sujet pour moi donc le
système est amené à évoluer il faut
évidemment sécuriser ça très très vite
d'autant plus que là aujourd'hui les les
projets de grande ampleur notamment
autour le père sont pas formellement
engagés quand ils l'ont quand ils le
seront il va y avoir un le risque en
tout cas d'un appel d'air et il faut
savoir que nos experts ils sont
utilisables directement quoi aller en
plus le DF le enfin les exploitants les
connaissent puisqu'on contact au
quotidien puisque c'est leur quotidien
c'est discuter avec les opérateurs donc
c'est un vrai c'est un vrai sujet
monsieur saumon accélération des
installations nucléaires est-ce que ça
va fluidifier les processus alors un sur
la sur la loi indépendamment du sujet de
l'organisation du contrôle je m'étais
exprimé de devant les sénateurs nous sur
la loi je mets de côté le nouvel
amendement là sur la loi elle-même nous
considéré comme d'un point de vue sur
thème nucléaire il y avait pas de
régression c'est-à-dire que ça changeait
rien au processus d'instruction
notamment ça ce qu'on a vérifié ces
salaires raccourcis c'est pas un pointe
voilà donc c'est pas du tout le cas ce
serait même plutôt le contraire donc sur
cette partie là on a on avait aussi nous
on considère qu'il y a pas de notre
point de vue sur tes nucléaire expertise
de sûreté qui a pas de sujet sur
l'évolution du système
je peux pas je peux pas répondre à ce
stade c'est-à-dire que que c'est le
point que je m'en suis tout à l'heure
c'est à dire essayer d'être plus
efficace tout le temps c'est une
préoccupation quelle que soit
l'organisation dans laquelle on est
c'est-à-dire que l'objectif c'est c'est
l'objectif de l'URSS c'est pas de
ralentir les opérateurs l'objectif de
l'URSS c'est d'éviter les accidents
cléaires non mais genre faut garder sans
tête j'ai quand même que c'est un peu
compliqué dans notre boulot parce qu'on
fait bien notre travail quand il se
passe rien quoi non mais c'est la
réalité
voilà
madame la Présidente sur les mouvements
sociaux et les cinq cas donc je reviens
à ce que j'ai de faire il faut laisser
griser l'avenir à l'irsen il y a un bon
dialogue social c'est aussi un constat
de c'est aussi un constat de la Cour des
comptes donc évidemment je souhaite je
pense que ce sera le cas que nous
organisations syndicales seront
évidemment attentives au fait que
les salariés soient le mieux accompagnés
possible et donc je fais le vœu et je
pense que ça se passera on arrivera à
construire un dialogue social pour
mettre en place cette évolution si elle
devait venir sur les 25% ASN donc
direction un large champ puisque c'est
ce qui a été voulu à la création de
lassitude la création des instituts le
choix politique qui a été fait par le
Parlement et le gouvernement c'est de
créer un organisme en charge de
l'évaluation de l'ensemble des risques
liés au rayonnement ionisants donc c'est
la sûreté les accidents c'est la radio
protection protégée le public
l'environnement les patients les
travailleurs des rayons c'est la
sécurité
donc le pré prévenir les actes
terroristes et donc dans ce champ là il
y a 25% pour la SN il y a 40% pour la
recherche qui en baisse légère tous les
ans mais une fine et depuis 10 ans on a
dû perdre une dizaine de pour cent et
puis après il y a des activités de
surveillance il y a des activités
d'appui à au ministère par exemple on
peut rendre des avis sur les radiations
liées au scanner pour le ministère de la
Santé par exemple on fait des études des
petits idéologies sur les scanners des
au cerveau sur les scanners sur les
enfants on a rendu le résultat d'une
étude il y a pas très longtemps suivi
cancer du sein etc donc on a une
activité importante en radioprotection
dans le domaine de la santé c'est aussi
vrai dans le domaine de la santé
environnement
à titre d'exemple on travaille beaucoup
sur le laragon le radon c'est quand même
les évaluations parce qu'on peut pas
cibler le peut pas cibler les les
cancers du poumon en fonction de leur
origine mais
10% des des décès de cancer du poumon
sont attribués aura donc c'est un sujet
de santé publique c'est 3000 personnes
par an donc ça c'est un sujet sur quelle
IRSN travail on travaille à la fois dans
la modélisation mais aussi dans
l'intervention
la modélisation les études des
pneumologiques vous voyez donc c'est
c'est un sujet important c'est 3000
morts par an quoi
personne de l'ASN comment tout ça c'est
des sujets qu'il faut traiter je
comprends qu'aujourd'hui ça devrait
partir avec mais il faut quand même
regarder ce sujet voilà c'est un sujet
qu'on peut pas laisser tomber voilà donc
ça ça fait évidemment il y a les
autorités de sécurité sur tes défenses
les autorités de sécurité donc tout ça
ça fait 100 % dont 25 % pour la SN
très
rapidement c'était juste un petit oubli
est-ce que dans le contexte actuel avec
cette relance du nucléaire avec ses
nouveaux
ces nouveaux types de réacteurs est-ce
que vous pensez que la dualité gardait
tout son sens ou est-ce qu'il y avait
nécessité d'avoir une réinterrogation
sur notre système moi je consacre le
cm2l fonctionne maintenant je suis tout
à fait ouvert à ce qu'on serait
interroge j'ai pas de problème là-dessus
avec l'ensemble des acteurs donc
évidemment les parlementaires qui me
sont essentiels c'est eux qui ont porté
sur les fonds bâtissements ce système
donc les parlementaires l'Autorité de
sûreté l'IRSN les autres acteurs comme
comme les clients je pense que si on
fait une réflexion globale il faudrait
aussi élargir à l'ensemble du champ
Félia sm mais nous on est tout à fait
favorable disposé à faire ça
aujourd'hui je considère que le système
le système fonctionne néanmoins on a
obtenu un certain nombre de moyens suite
au rapport de la Cour des comptes qui
pointait les enjeux de soustabilité de
l'Institut le gouvernement et le
Parlement nous a attribué des moyens
dans le cadre du PLF 2023 si nous permet
d'ailleurs de nous organiser par rapport
aux grands chantiers qui viennent dans
la logique que j'ai décrit tout à
l'heure donc avec la SN et
EDF pour préparer l'arrivée des gros
dossiers Opel mais il y a aussi aussi
géo par exemple sur lequel on vient de
recevoir le dossier de toute façon de
création je crois c'est 10000 pages
voilà donc il y a du travail à venir
mais on s'est organisé enfin c'est notre
métier
je suis toute petite question vous avez
parlé effectivement de votre expertise
sur les traitements médicaux est-ce que
vous l'avez aussi sur les traitements
ionisants pour les aliments
potentiellement oui mais en fait le
sujet de le sujet des rayonnements
ionisants sur les aliments c'est plus un
sujet de qualité sanitaire de
dégradation de qualité du produit plus
qu'un sujet rayonnement ionisant donc
potenti on a entendu une question mais
c'est pas un sujet c'est pas un sujet
majeur on fait on fait on fait pour le
compte de la SN l'expertise des
installations de dionisations il y a des
grosses installations d'utilisation qui
bien qu'il faut plutôt de la
polymérisation ou de stérilisation de
matériel médical notamment donc là par
contre on a intérêt à se faisait
l'installation c'est les petites
installations
avec des gros sources et avec des
opérateurs qui ont pas forcément la
compétence des gros opérateurs
nucléaires donc on est assez attentif à
ces sujets
peut-être avant nous plus de questions
en sortant de ces deux auditions que
nous n'avons mais c'est pas de votre
faute ni à vous Monsieur le Directeur
général ni au président de la
snouidaniel
oui peut-être parce que ça a été évoqué
tout à l'heure avec la SN on l'a survolé
tout de suite mais on a été témoin
encore hier
il y a des choses et des entreprises
françaises dans le domaine public qui
sont à la pointe sur le nouveau
nucléaire de petits réacteurs et
lorsqu'on les avait auditionnés sur le
texte du l'accélération de mon nucléaire
il nous disait justement comment quai
d'expertise pour les accompagner et que
le pas de temps dans lequel il pourrait
effectivement dans les cinq ans proposés
de passer à des stades de de production
était largement réel anti par
l'insuffisance d'expertise
est-ce que cette
ce contexte nouveau dans la nouvelle
configuration
ce vide sera comblé ou pas alors les
sémer déjà de travail depuis un certain
temps sur sur ces sujets c'est vrai que
des réacteurs qui sont qui vont dans le
bon sens d'un point de vue de la sûreté
a priori puisque plus qu'un actif et
plus et facile de enfin moi c'est
difficile on peut le dire comme ça de de
de traiter un accident grave néanmoins
il y a du travail à faire notamment sur
le système passif on a on a grâce au
plan de relance on est en train de
construire un Cadarache une installation
pour étudier les systèmes passifs d'un
point de vue expérimental pour pour être
dans nos codes donc ça c'est aussi un
exemple de d'interaction expertise
recherche c'est un station qui vaut 9
millions et qui va permettre de
d'alimenter nos codes pour mieux
expertiser ses SMS alors pour répondre à
votre question nous en tant que en tant
qu'rsn on peut pas faire les études de
sûreté à la place de ces opérateurs
c'est plutôt des organismes comme le CEA
qui peuvent le faire par contre nous ce
qu'on peut faire c'est de la formation
et mettre à disposition des codes ça on
a beaucoup de codes donc c'est des codes
qu'on pourrait mettre à disposition en
délivrant une formation etc donc nous je
l'ai déjà dit
un certain nombre de fois on est tout à
fait disposés à faut regarder de moyens
de disponibilité que ça parce que les
experts sont pas extensibles mais on
serait tout à fait disponible la limite
déontologiques c'est qu'on veut pas
faire les études à leur place parce que
sinon on se retrouve les expertiser
nous-mêmes je pense que ça c'est plutôt
le boulot de des opérateurs nucléaires
notamment le CEVA en tout cas nous on
est tout à fait disponible sur la
formation
expliquer les approches de sûreté on
peut même aller assez loin sur et puis
sur les côtes puisqu'on a un certain
nombre de code comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure qu'on vend qu'on licencie en
sens donner des licences donc ça on est
on est disponible
très bien il me reste à vous remercier
tous les deux Madame et Monsieur le
Directeur général de cette audition
peut-être reviendront nous vers vous
voilà pour des questions complémentaires
dans le temps qui nous reste pour
prendre une décision sur voilà cette
opportunité merci beaucoup